[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i am so excited for this episode and i
am also intimidated i have a mess of
notes in front of me which we will
discuss my guest is noah feldman you can
find him on twitter at noah r feldman
feldman noah is a harvard professor
ethical philosopher and advisor public
intellectual
religious scholar and historian and
author of ten books including his latest
the broken constitution subtitled
lincoln slavery and the refounding of
america he's also a hyper polyglot and
we're going to probably talk about that
right at the beginning it tells you
something when that can be omitted in
the bio moving on feldman is host of the
deep background podcast a policy and
public affairs columnist for bloomberg
opinion and a former contributing writer
for the new york times he served as
senior constitutional advisor to the
coalition provisional authority in iraq
and subsequently advised members of the
iraqi governing council on the drafting
of iraq's interim constitution he earned
his ab summa [ __ ] laude from harvard
finishing first in his class selected as
a road scholar he earned a d fill which
i just learned how to pronounce properly
from oxford university writing his
dissertation on aristotle's ethics he
received his jd from yale law school and
clerked for justice david suter of the
u.s supreme court noah's ten books also
include divided by god america's church
state problem and what we should do
about it what we owe iraq war and the
ethics of nation building cool war
subtitle the united states china and the
future of global competition scorpions
the battles and triumphs of fdr's great
supreme court justices and the three
lives of james madison genius partisan
president you can find them on twitter
as mentioned at noah r feldman instagram
noah r feldman and all things noah can
be found at noaa
hyphenfeldman.com noah welcome to the
show so nice to see you it's great to
see you too tim thank you so much for
having me
and i will begin with the language piece
and i'm gonna i'm gonna segue there
by
stating up front for people who don't
know
that we have a shared deep interest in
languages although you put me to shame
and what i was thinking is i looked at
probably 12 sheets of paper in front of
me before we got started i thought to
myself
i wanted to look it up because i was
going to say this on the show and i was
like you know what i should really check
to see what that means it's used in
argentina
to mean what a mess what a mess and so i
looked it up and it actually comes from
what is called lunfardo which is this
sort of italian adopted
street slang used initially by kind of
lower classes and criminals and quilombo
means a mess scandal uproar disorder or
conflict in the past quilombo strictly
referred to brothels or so-called houses
of ill-repute
however
as the term evolved it began to be
applied to disorganized or messy
conditions or situations of conflict now
i'm just using it to refer to my notes
and
where to begin and i highlighted one
thing and that is
related to your languages you're fluent
in english hebrew arabic french you can
speak and read conversational korean
read aramaic latin some greek spanish
italian and german
how
does this happen where did this start
i think it started basically in a
kilometer thanks thanks for teaching me
that new word um of a of a childhood
where my parents definitely thought that
we should live in a bunch of different
worlds
and they before i was born had spent
time in afghanistan
and had afghan friends that i knew when
i was growing up and actually had two
afghan teenagers living with us when i
was a little kid
and then we went and spent a year in
israel and
i i don't remember this because i was
too little but i have the pictures of
myself on a backpack on my dad's back in
front of the acropolis in athens and
then in front of the pyramids in egypt
and on the temple mount in jerusalem and
so i think i was just being exposed to a
million languages or maybe not a million
but a lot of languages when i was a
really really small kid and my dad would
always tell the story about being in
cairo
and i was running around and i was i
think like one and a half
and i was i called my dad abba which is
hebrew or actually it's aramaic for for
dad and i was saying
and my dad was freaking out because
we're like in the middle of egypt and
this kid is speaking hebrew to his
father
and you know it is a time literally
between the 1967 and 1973 wars where
israel and egypt were like not only at
war with each other in the midst of like
an actual shooting war over the suez
canal but like they were between two
megawars
and
people came up to him and were like so
nice your son already speaks arabic and
he's only one year old he's saying
so my dad was like oh thank goodness
you know like these languages are
basically all the same and i remember
being told that story from an early
early age and i think the takeaway all
of my dad's stories had takeaways and i
think the takeaway was a language
matters b
even people who are really really mad at
each other have a lot of overlap
including overlap of language
and i think that always stayed with me
we're definitely going to
go deeper on this but i want to say also
as
just a backdrop that
as i was doing research for this and i
always enjoy the sort of pretext of
the interview to do all this google
sleuthing which would otherwise be
really creepy
i just came to realize that perhaps i
should think of you as
someone who studies
the code
of
human behavior whether that takes the
form of
absorbed code in a sense through say
language you assimilate at a super young
age
whether that is
say a constitution
or some type of sort of consciously
constructed
code of a sort blockchain might also be
an example
and certainly
you know languages is one arena in which
you
seem to have really cut your teeth
in the beginning you absorbed languages
but then you began to study
languages why dedicate so much time and
energy and how did that happen
well first of all thank you for that way
of putting it which i love and it's
better than i could have put it myself
i think i was trying to decode the world
around me
so
my parents sent me to a jewish school
where they taught us hebrew
and they also took us to the middle east
when i was old enough to remember it and
i remember being a little kid in israel
and seeing street signs in hebrew arabic
and english and having really no idea at
that age that there was a very
complicated layered history of that with
not a lot of getting along and a whole
lot of fighting but an aspiration via
these different languages to try to get
along
and i just thought well if there's
multiple languages i'm supposed to know
them because they were sending me to a
school where they taught me this
language and then there it was on a
street sign so i thought okay i guess
i'm supposed to figure these things out
and that actually led me to go and study
arabic
in the kind of naive childish and in my
defense i was only
you know
15 years old or 14 years old aspiration
to
understand the world and you know then i
maybe i could bring peace to the middle
east you know that didn't work out so
well um but you know the idea was to
decode
these things that are otherwise
unavailable and when you there's
actually nothing more
frustrating in life than hearing someone
speak a language that you don't speak
because you know there's a whole
universe going on there you can see the
animation you know there are emotions
you can recognize something and you
don't know what they're saying and so
for me the impulse to decode is to sort
of get behind there and to know what's
going on underneath
so i just want to highlight 1415 because
there is this
myth i certainly think it's a myth
that to learn a language
speak it fluently we could debate what
fluent means but let's just say
conversationally
at a reasonably high level that you need
to learn it when you are in the single
digits
and that is
patently false uh
certainly it's been my experience i
really started
learning languages at 15 or 16.
and you have a long list but let's start
with arabic
so 1415
you set out to learn arabic and there
are many different flavors of arabic but
once you were
reasonably competent with arabic how did
that change
your
universe
it broke it i mean it changed my world
view radically and totally
and
that's because
when you learn a language it puts you in
the thought world
of the people who speak it
and you no longer are seeing them as an
outsider
imagining what they might think when
they speak to themselves but you're
actually a participant you may not be a
member of the group but you can
participate because you can speak the
language
and since i'd been raised in this milieu
that was
you know very israel-focused very jewish
there were all kinds of ideas about what
arabic speakers were like what arabic
was like
what the world of
you know of the arab people was
and just to see that from the opposite
perspective
it blew my mind at a very early age and
i think very few things have had as big
an influence on me because i just
realized that things just looked
different from an alternative
perspective they weren't necessarily
better or worse they were just
really really fundamentally
distinct and that made me realize that
to put it very bluntly a lot of what i'd
been taught
you could characterize as not having
been true from someone else's
perspective
it's not that anybody was consciously
lying to me they were just giving me
their perspective
and suddenly i was hearing pretty much
180 degrees the opposite perspective
and that is the most useful lesson you
could possibly give a young teenager
trying to make sense of the world
someone always sees things the opposite
way that you see them
why did
you end up in egypt
with potential
i imagine you know conflict risk
with your
parents
how did why why were you there
you know i've talked to my parents a lot
about why they like to travel the way
they did when we were little and
you know they were in israel for the
year my dad had an academic fellowship
there my mom was in graduate school so
she was working on her dissertation but
however you do that when you're you've
got one little kid and you've got
another one on the way and she somehow
managed to pull that off
and they were like we're here egypt's
not that far away
let's go check out egypt
and
you know i mean i guess it was close
enough to the 60s that there was still
this idea that you just kind of threw
your kid
in the back of the car literally and
just went
and you know he couldn't go directly
from israel to egypt at the time so that
meant they had to go
via i think they went via cyprus
probably by boat um if i remember
correctly and you know they were just
like
what the heck there were no there were
no car seats in that world let's just
put it that way so i think they just
wanted to see what it was like
and then once they were there you know
they were also an important element they
were americans and americans could go
anywhere we were we've been incredibly
privileged you know through our lives
and also our parents lives that that
passport that blue passport mostly lets
you in
almost wherever you want to go people
might not like us very much but they
pretty much always let us in and then if
they don't we invade them so that's
probably not such a good thing but that
is a habit that we have
for people listening i want you to know
we're not going to focus on languages
for an hour or anything like that i do
want to spend a little more time on it
because
and i want you to stress test feel free
to stress test anything i say that
sounds like bs but
we begin to function it seems you know
as adults and interact as a society
using
words that reflect concepts and those
words and concepts form narratives that
drive our lives right these are
invisible scripts in a way
and
i think that's going to tie into a lot
of what we end up discussing so i want
to spend a little bit more time on
language and
the way i want to do that first is by
asking you about and you can correct my
pronunciation here but
in english
dr bishai
yes and wilson be shy yeah okay be shy
so i want to read something from
wordsmithsblog.com
and i believe these are your words
so at harvard i studied biblical hebrew
and a great deal of medieval
philosophical hebrew i also studied
arabic primarily medieval philosophical
arabic but i did take a course on modern
colloquial arabic given by dr bishai
how did he end up
teaching you colloquial
arabic
so dr bishai wilson bishai who's kind of
a hero of mine was a major important
person in my life even before i took
that class because he was the one who
when i showed up and wanted to enroll at
the harvard summer school
as a young teen i've just finished ninth
grade
and i wanted to take arabic
let me take his class and i had the
following experience i went into his
office to discuss this with him
and
he he was a very formal guy so it was
like the summer and he was wearing a
full suit
in my memory he even had a vest on
although i might be a magic vest
and like a big tie
and he was very formal he spoke in this
very mellifluous deep bass kind of voice
and he said to me you wish to study the
arabic language
i said yes dr bisho i do he said you may
study the arabic language and then i
said but i have a problem which is that
you can't sign up for the summer school
unless you're 16 and i'm not 16.
and he said
hold on a moment and he picked up the
phone and he called the registrar of the
summer school and they had a
conversation
and i didn't think it was going very
well from what i could hear on one end
of it he hung up and he said i have good
news
you will study arabic i was like great
he said there is only one condition
you may not pay tuition
and you may not take the final
examination
so basically he had gotten on the phone
he had called the registrar the
registrar and said no i'm not gonna let
you register some like little kid for
your class and he had said okay no
problem and then he hung up the phone
and just said okay you can come to my
class it's my class you come to my class
you're just not going to pay and you're
not going to show up the day of the
final exam and he opened up the world of
the arabic language to me and he was a
very distinctive guy he had his own
book that he used to teach that he had
invented he had his own tapes that we
listened to in the old-fashioned
language lab where we'd go and listen to
them on
you know on tape decks i remember that i
did that too
and it worked and
i loved it and i you know worked my tail
off and unlike i guess all the other
people in harvard summer school who were
old enough to go out and party i wasn't
so i'm so i'm doing my homework every
night
and later when i went to college i took
this class that i that you were
referring to there which was a kind of
amazing class he was egyptian and he
introduced us to modern standard arabic
which is what the newscasters speak but
he also had these linguistic tricks they
were literally like a code that he had
worked out and he taught us these tricks
in the course so you could translate in
real time almost like an algorithm your
formal modern standard arabic into
egyptian colloquial arabic
and it was kind of like a bizarre and
fascinating thing that it worked so well
but it did it just it worked like a
charm
and he he loved all of the students who
most of us have studied arabic with him
before and just final story about this
he kept on referring to the exam as the
banquet he would say
you have you have eaten the meals and
now you must attend the banquet and then
when the semester came to an end he
literally
did not give us a final exam he was like
you all have learned very well and he
actually took us out to dinner
instead of a final exam
i mean i was just like that is what a
good teacher is he knew what each of us
knew it was good enough for him boom
we're done here
that is such an incredible story what a
character
what a personality he really was and he
taught a whole generation of harvard
students to speak arabic
and on the egyptian arabic side
for those who don't know could you just
give
people an idea of the spectrum of
arabic right because this applies to so
many languages and it applies to so many
things just like spanish and argentina
is actually spanish in the provinces of
argentina is not the same as spanish in
capital federal in buenos aires it's not
the same it is not the same spanish
spoken in spain etc even though they all
fall under this umbrella term of spanish
what does the spectrum of arabic look
like i think the spectrum of arabic is
maybe the biggest of almost any language
that you can still call the same
language and part of the reason for that
is you know when the original arabs you
know following the prophet muhammad came
out of arabia
in the 7th and 8th centuries they
conquered a large part of the known
world
and
only a small number of them
went out there and they brought their
arabic which was the arabic of arabia
which is why it was called arabic
but then they assimilated into all of
the local cultures ranging all the way
from you know the iraq iran border in
the east all the way to
morocco in the west and then up all the
way into spain so that's an enormous
geographical span and they were
encountering different languages
wherever they went and the local
languages
basically merged to some degree with the
formal arabic that had that had come
along and so the result is that over the
next you know roughly 1300 years
the daily spoken languages
diverged even as the written language
remained pretty standard everywhere and
as the language let's say of the quran
and then later the language of
newspapers
and newscasters remained pretty stable
so the result is that if you were
listening to an iraqi speaking
colloquial everyday iraqi arabic
and an egyptian
and a tunisian and a moroccan they are
so different that as you get further and
further apart they literally would not
be able to understand each other so it's
literally the case that someone who only
speaks iraqi dialect would not be able
to understand very well
someone who only spoke moroccan or
tunisian dialect they're almost
different languages and what people do
understand comes mostly from watching tv
shows that are you know that are
broadcast all over the region so for
example in the 50s and 60s the egyptian
tv stations were the dominant ones
and so actually people all over the arab
world can still often understand
egyptian arabic because they just
watched it on tv and over time they
picked it up so it's like a fascinating
aspect of arabic and it's also really
frustrating because when you land in a
country where you don't speak the
dialect and i had this experience in
tunisia uh you know in the early right
after the arab spring when i spent a lot
of time there
you know you get off the plane
you're talking to people and everyone
can understand modern standard arabic so
you can make yourself understood really
well you just sound like you know you're
a newscaster or something and then they
answer you back and if it's an educated
person they answer you in modern arabic
and then you're having a conversation
but if they answer you in their local
colloquial
you're like smiling and you have no idea
what they just said no idea and then you
have to say to them oh would you please
speak you know formal arabic which you
can't always say to someone who hasn't
had you know advanced schooling then the
most embarrassing part is then
uneducated people will say oh you speak
such a beautiful arabic you speak so
much better than we do and you're like
no i don't speak better than you do
i just speak you know newscaster arabic
but they're taught that that's somehow
better or higher and so they're really
like deferential and respectful and
makes you feel awful because in fact the
whole point is you don't actually speak
their colloquial and it will take you a
month to be able to like even you know
order in a restaurant
well it makes me think of this time i
was watching a boxing match with a
friend and one of the boxers
was
from the uk and he's being interviewed
after the fight my friend said wow he's
really smart i said no he's not he just
has the queen's english as an accent
and i'm going to ask you about aramaic
but first i want to just point out to
people how interconnected all these
things are so you mentioned
tricks
almost like an algorithm right
for converting this modern standard
arabic into colloquial
arabic or specifically i guess
colloquial egyptian arabic
and even the world algorithm i believe
comes from like al khadizmi or
some mathematician slash
astronomer who has a statute dedicated
to him i want to say in uzbekistan which
is where i spent some time with kevin
kelly
so that al of algorithm is pronounced in
english we see that everywhere in
arabic right al-qaeda and
what does that all mean
all it just means the
it's like a definite article you're
completely right and it goes in front of
proper nouns
and it goes in front of
names too
and so almost every time you see the al
prefix in a word that we use in english
it comes from arabic and it almost
always comes from arabic via spanish
because the arabs were in spain and then
there was this long complicated you know
800 year struggle over whether the
christians or the muslims would control
spain and if you're struggling with
someone for 800 years you're sharing a
lot of culture and civilization along
the way and there was there are a lot of
high moments when people are getting
along and so
it's also true whenever you're in latin
america and speaking spanish
words that start with al are all over
the language you know even more than
they are in english and every single one
of those words basically with no
exception is actually an arabic word and
that's like totally fascinating to me
it's super fascinating i mean you have
arabic words used widely in south
america right as a result
exactly
and
who knows i mean how the sort of
confluence and dispersion of different
languages led to i don't know the
etymology and
sort of background of these words but
it's it's really this uh
right this melting pot
and
i want to give a tip for people just to
take this from
super intimidating to hopefully
approachable
the tricks are a real thing these
algorithms and i recall
so when you see a list of languages that
people know it's it's not starting from
scratch every time
by
by
any stretch of the imagination and i
recall going to brazil for the first
time this is a long time ago
and i spoke a decent amount of spanish
and there was in fact
i want to say a state department guide
and i bought the print copy it was very
hard to get a hold of it may have been
from a a different governmental body but
nonetheless it was from the us
government printed in english and it was
a guide to learning portuguese
for
speakers non-native speakers of spanish
it's so cool
and it just showed you how to convert
right and
it was incredibly helpful and it allowed
me to cheat but as you said if you speak
portugal which is you know some mongrel
hybrid of basic portuguese and decent
spanish you can ask questions but
understanding the answers is a whole
whole separate kettle of fish there's
some kind of metaphor there i always
think of like i can i know the question
to ask and i can sort of understand your
answer but i don't understand all of
your answers there's some situations
where that's really bad like when you're
a traveler and the answer involves going
right and going left and you know those
words but you don't exactly know what
they mean every where we're in between
you know you're like you think you're
following the algorithm but you actually
but you actually aren't
what does uh and i'm i i know i'm not
pronouncing this properly in arabic but
what does al qaeda mean or al-qaeda i
don't know how to say it yeah so if you
wanted to say it in formal arabic you'd
say al haida and that means the base it
literally means
and it was the name that bin laden and
those around him gave to their
organization
after the us began to help
people fight the soviets who had invaded
afghanistan
and what bin laden's business was
basically you know he was a rich kid a
super rich kid
and
he went to afghanistan and he was trying
to organize people from outside of
afghanistan primarily from the arabic
speaking world but also from elsewhere
to come to afghanistan and fight the
jihad against the soviets
and you know if this doesn't screw with
your mind nothing will we supported him
we liked this we wanted people from all
over the arab world who were inspired by
islam to go and fight against the soviet
union which was our enemy
and so the base meant the base of
people who got together to fight the
soviets and that's how the organization
got its name
wow
you know i just have to reiterate i'm
i'm
so excited for this conversation and
simultaneously knowing we're gonna only
cover a fraction so
i
i'm gonna preemptively invite you back
for
round two and maybe multiple rounds i'm
gonna focus on the personal here not too
too personal but the the personal first
second and then we're going to dig into
some of your other areas of expertise
and this is the basic question
and uh i think a lot of people will
wonder this
all right you're a law professor you
teach three to four courses you're a
columnist you write two to three columns
a week your podcast host
so you take two podcasts book author
on average one book every two years
ethical advisor you advise facebook ebay
other tech companies
you're raising two teenage kids
while still taking off nights weekends
jewish holidays and
as i have it on
on good uh
good authority
occasionally sleeping in until 10 a.m
while not drinking caffeine
so what the hell noah how do you do all
of this
and why no caffeine
i really like caffeine but i think i'm
unbearable to myself on it and i'm sure
i'm unbearable to others on it too
i think it's just metabolic luck you
know i have
i wake up and i have a lot of energy to
do stuff and i like doing stuff that's
fun i do get plenty of sleep which i
think helps a lot i mean i do i'm one of
these people who believes that and i've
heard you say this on your show too that
if you under sleep yourself sure then
you're gonna need caffeine or some other
substance to get you going but if you
get enough sleep you don't need the
caffeine and you can just blast hard the
rest of the time and sort of you know
suck all of the juice out of life
so i think that's the reason that i that
i don't use caffeine
also as i said i think it makes me super
irritating like i get
extremely up in everybody else's face
and
extremely intense and i can actually
feel my heart beating too fast
when i when i use it i can literally
like put my hand on my chest and feel
the vibration and realize that doesn't
sound good
so that still
leaves the question of how you
structure your time
or think about
i don't want to say time management
because maybe that's not it
life management such that you can do all
of these things because there are plenty
of people who have
let's just call it
good
good genetics
good metabolism who have
an abundance of energy who nonetheless
cannot harness that energy
to do one of these things let alone this
long list that i just provided
while while having time off
so let me first say i i want to thank
you for getting me to think about this
systematically not just in this
conversation but it was actually when i
met you and we were sort of starting to
chat about this and i actually had never
thought about
how i arranged my life at all i just
kind of did it but now i've actually
thought about a little bit and i think
the answer if there is one is whatever
i'm doing in that moment
i really try to be completely focused
and present on that moment and never
thinking about the thing that comes next
and over time i think i train myself to
be able to do that so
you know if i get up in the morning and
walk my daughter to the bus she's more
than old enough that she does not need
me to walk her to the bus she's maybe
even a little embarrassed by it but i
have this theory that if you're there as
a parent sometimes in the middle of the
routine like a meaningful moment will
happen and it might not happen most days
when it's you know seven in the morning
we're bleary-eyed and neither of us is
in the greatest mood but if we're both
there you know one out of ten days or
even if it's one out of a hundred days
something will happen and i really try
to just be present for that
if i sit down in front of my computer
and say okay i'm going to write a column
now i literally shut out everything
except for that column
and i turn on my voice recognition
software because i do everything by
voice recognition software
and i
just focus completely and i've trained
myself to just put myself into flow
and i do it i don't worry about whether
it's good or it's bad
i just get it out there i'll worry about
whether it's going to be when i'm done
with it and then it's done and then i
stop take a deep breath
read it over i hit send to my editor
thank god i have an editor so that i'm
not reliant on myself to know whether it
was any good or not an editor will tell
you this one was terrible throw this one
out
but i send it to the editor and i put it
out of my mind completely it's gone
and then i do the next thing and
by doing it that way i think i'm just
saving the time waste that we have
in
a kind of
self-questioning that inevitably
sinks in the rest of the time now you
might say what's missing from this is
self-reflection and honestly i think for
many years of my life that's true i
think for many years of my life i was
missing genuine self-reflection like i
had i had fake self-reflection where i
had conversations and thought about
things but i wasn't really really really
doing it
and it wasn't till my late 30s when
um i went to see a shrink for the first
time because i was having a you know
kind of little early you know early
mid-life meltdown
that i
actually engaged in that kind of
self-reflection and i did not know how
to do it i really didn't know how to do
it and i would say to myself after
therapy oh my god i'm failing at therapy
like i know i just wasted that whole
session and i kept on saying that for a
long time
what do you mean by failed
what does failing look like how how
how does one fail at that
well i guess the reason i thought i was
failing is i was mistakenly thinking
that therapy was like every other thing
that i do you know a concentrated 45
minute session where you're supposed to
accomplish something and i would go in
and on the way out i was like i didn't
accomplish anything i don't feel better
i don't feel worse i didn't have any
deep self-revelation like what the hell
did i do you know i was and in the sense
i was only doing it wrong because i
thought i was doing it wrong like you
can't do therapy wrong but i thought
that there was a way to do it right and
therefore there must be a way that i
wasn't doing it and also i wasn't
getting any better so then i thought
okay you know i really am doing it wrong
and then over time took a long time i
came to realize that just sitting there
and being in the moment and letting it
happen and not
saying okay i'm going to go in to
achieve this and i'm going to leave
having achieved that was the only way
therapy was ever going to do anything
and i wish i could tell you that like i
thought of that quickly but i didn't
so for sake of clarity
you
ended up viewing
therapy is almost a meditative
time for non-accomplishment through
which you found it therapeutically
valuable yeah i think that's it i mean i
think it's that i don't know about
meditative because you are talking
you know
and depending on who your therapist is
the therapist might also be talking some
don't like to say very much
but
i think what i realized was that
you have to just let things bubble up
you can't force it
you cannot force your way into having
successful
talk therapy
and that was the the take away from me
and i know most people listening to this
are like uh duh like you have to be
pretty dumb not to have realized that
like that says it on the bottle you know
but i i was that kind of dumb and i
think it derived from you know having
this approach to everything else where i
thought okay what am i gonna do what am
i supposed to be doing here i'm gonna
totally do it and i'm gonna do it in a
total concentrated way and i'm going to
know at the end of it that i
accomplished it so that i can move on to
the next thing
voice recognition
how long have you used voice recognition
since it wasn't that good
i've used it since uh
2002 and when i wrote my first book
which i did right after 9 11
i
wrote that book on a little laptop
and
i screwed up my wrists from using the
mouse on the laptop
and
i remember in the middle of it
i actually went to like the doctor
because i was like i'm having this
really weird wrist and arm pain and i
have just no idea what this pain is
and
i was actually newly married and i was
like i don't know like i'm newly married
like i have never really
extensively you know slept in the same
bed with another person before does it
have something to do with with that i
mean it's absurd thing to say the doctor
was like okay describe what you do every
day and i'm like uh
i sit on my computer he's like show me
how i sat down i put my hands out he's
like does your arm hurt i was like oh
it's really hurting and he was like you
have an rsi
and so i was like okay well what do i do
because
you know i realized that i'd written a
book rsi is repetitive stress injury
exactly yeah a repetitive stress injury
and it turned out the only real answer
was don't engage in that physical
movement
and
at the time
there still weren't very many touch
screens um you could maybe get one if
you spend a ton of money on it
and most computers required a mouse as
your primary interface and i just
couldn't use
the mouse and i couldn't hold my wrists
in a good position for typing
so
i started using voice recognition
software a very close friend of mine um
who had actually he had a much more
admirable injury he had injured his his
hand lifting
it's an incredibly brilliant guy who was
also like in incredible shape and he was
like oh yeah try this voice recognition
software and i started using it and at
the time it wasn't so great but it was
much better than being in constant pain
and it actually had a huge influence on
me because since then pretty much every
word that i've written
comes first in draft form from speech i
i talk it
whether it's a column or a book or
something in between
what technology do you use now what does
the setup look like
and
and what are best practices because i
when i hear voice recognition i think
sitting down and
best as you can stream of consciousness
speaking out a rough draft is there an
outlining that comes beforehand et
cetera et cetera so if you could just
speak to the current day best practices
for you
i use a product called dragon
naturallyspeaking which i've been really
loyal to over the years as they have
continued to improve it and it was just
luck that i picked one that turned out
to be one of the leading ones in the
industry i think that the company that
makes it ended up also licensing their
technology to a lot of other voice
recognition systems
and
for me the best practices are and you
used to have to have a very good
microphone
and now the processing power of the
computers is great enough that you don't
need as good a microphone because it can
handle imprecision
i'm sure the quality of the microphones
is also really improved so you can sit
in front of your computer
and i do it by looking at what appears
on the screen when i speak
and i do try to speak not quite as fast
as i do the rest of the time even though
i do talk pretty fast in general
even when i'm talking to the computer
and i think of it as
though
i had an audience
i imagine that i'm telling someone
what my ideas are
and to the extent there's an outline
for me it's only that i think
where do i want to end up
and then i just start talking and try to
get there
and if i feel a need for an outline in
midstream i'll say
there are three points that i wish to
make
you know and then i'll start listing
them and it might turn out that there's
two or six or a hundred or you know that
they're all stupid but the great thing
is you can delete it all later
and you see the words magically
appearing in front of you as you go and
i find it way less intimidating than the
blank piece of paper
because you've always got something to
say this is my current problem this is
my current
hang up which might just be
a failing of moral character and
strength on my side but yeah the blank
page i've i've sort of psyched myself
out for the last year year and a half
wow i mean that's incredible to hear
because you obviously have been such an
extraordinary writer and you also write
in a very fluid accessible way thank you
that's actually really really
fascinating
and i i remember once reading tim that
you talked about maybe it was your
senior essay that you had a hard time
getting into that but then once you got
into it you did it
yeah it's something it's something i've
struggled with the idea of using
voice recognition as a lower friction
way into a first draft is very
interesting to me
could you give an example of say a
column or something you've done recently
what it looked like
when you
finished that first draft
sure and then just the evolution or
revision process
sure yeah and i should just say it's
very variable depending on
whether it's a you know a daily column
that you know is going to go out and you
know in the old days they would say
about newspaper columns that they wrap
yes do they wrap fish tomorrow
in the era of the internet they don't
even wrap fish like they're not even as
useful as being able to be fish rapping
so something like that you know if i
when i write it
i'll if i'm responding to something in
the world which is usually the way i
write a column
then
i usually have an argument a thing i
want to say
and i've usually gotten that down on
paper
often i'm missing good examples to prove
my point so often when i look it over at
the end of drafting it i say well that's
all very well and good but how do you
prove it so i go back in and i put an
example could you give us a concrete
example yeah exactly i'm done there i am
he shows you that i need it um so i just
i just wrote a column about uh justice
neil gorsuch um who's the first supreme
court justice ever to have
a doctorate
and i was trying to explain
why that mattered
for his what appears to be his real
aspiration which is to be the
heir to the late justice antonin scalia
as the conservative intellectual leader
of the court
and
so i began by kind of like saying this
that he you know he's the first one to
have a doctorate and describing how he
went back to get it in the middle of his
legal career which is kind of incredibly
impressive and i don't know how in the
world he did it and
then i said then i paused and said to
myself okay but how do i prove that he
really wants to be the intellectual
leader of the court and so i said okay
i'm going to use this really famous
decision he's only got one really famous
one so far so there weren't that many
examples that i could use
but this case called the boss dot case
from a couple years ago where he who's a
real deep conservative
ruled that the anti-discrimination laws
title vii
that prohibit workplace discrimination
and that say no workplace discrimination
because of sex
extend to discrimination against gay and
trans people
and so i pop that in as the example and
then i try to explain why it proved my
point
namely that he was saying something that
was completely the opposite of what his
ideological buddies believe
but he was doing it out of her principle
of consistency and the principle of
consistency is supposed to be that he
believes you're just supposed to read
laws according to their text you're not
supposed to look at their intention and
you're not supposed to look at the
purpose of the people who drafted them
you're just supposed to look at the text
and he said if you just look at the text
and it says because of sex
well if you're discriminating against a
gay person
because he's gay then you're
discriminating against him because
you're treating him differently because
he has sex with men then you would if it
were a woman who has sex with men
because that person would be straight
and so therefore you're discriminating
based on sex
trans person so it's like highly
formalistic
but he said well
i'm not going to pay any attention to
the intent of the people who wrote this
document who were not thinking about gay
rights
and who probably never heard of trans
rights
so
basically i then use that example to say
you see this is how someone who wants to
be an intellectual thinks
right
basically and as it happens in this
instance i'm really happy with the way
it came out
but
the form of logic is this highly weird
way of talking
that
a regular person interpreting a law
would never i don't think hit on yeah so
then i thought okay that's not a bad
example to show i hope that he really
wants to be an intellectual leader and
for that he needs to be consistent and
to be consistent he has to do something
that seems totally non-obvious and
actually makes a lot of people on his
side mad at him
you know this this example makes me
think of
scripture debate
and i although i haven't read the book
the premise i believe of this book
called misquoting jesus was looking at
the
linguistic
path that various
translations and mistranslations have
taken
that is such a fascinating
potentially problematic
approach
i mean that's a great great point the
comparison between the interpretation of
scripture
and the interpretation of the
constitution is a really tight one in
u.s history and in this book that i've
just finished
about about lincoln uh the broken
constitution i've actually got great
examples of
black abolitionists in the 1830s 40s and
50s
when we just if we've heard of an
abolitionist who's black from then we've
heard of frederick douglass but there
were actually dozens
of very serious committed black
abolitionists and they're actually
debating the constitution
and they're discussing explicitly
whether it should be compared to
scripture or not compared to scripture
because they are discussing whether you
should bring your personal
beliefs to bear on the interpretation or
whether you should interpret it in the
light of what the people who wrote it
believed
and that's a very similar debate to the
debate that happened around scripture
because protestants often thought in
america that you should interpret
scripture
partly in the light of your own
inspiration whereas catholics
historically thought that you should
interpret scripture in the light of what
the church fathers said that scripture
meant and what the church said that it
meant so those are totally different
viewpoints and so here you have these
black abolitionists who not for nothing
a lot of them had also studied religion
and some of them were ministers
were arguing exactly about should we
interpret the constitution that way or
not and it really mattered
because if you interpreted the
constitution according to the people who
wrote it they knew it was racist because
it protected slavery but if you
interpret according to their beliefs you
could read it against the grain
and you could say
that it was actually an anti-slavery
document or an anti-racist document
because you knew if you were a black
abolitionist in the 1830s 40s 50s that
racism was evil
we're going to come back to the broken
constitution 100
and in part i'm spending
my time or taking my time meandering
through different topics because you
very graciously informed me
or maybe foolishly informed me that we
do not have a hard stop so i have a
million in one questions we are going to
come back to the broken constitution but
before we get to that i think it's
important to ask
a few questions
what was your major undergrad
it was near eastern languages and
civilizations which was basically
hebrew jewish islamic
material basically from all different
historical periods
why law school
and maybe as a two-for-one bonus since
i i mentioned
before we started recording i was like
oh jd i'm familiar with that one if you
could give people a little trivia on
jd but why
law
i knew at the end of college and then
having you know gone and done you know a
doctorate in medieval islamic studies i
knew that every morning i'd be thrilled
to get up
and
enter the middle ages i knew it would be
fun for me every day
i was a little worried that at the end
of the day when i looked back and said
what contribution have i made
to the world how have i affected the
world i hope in a positive way
that i wasn't going to be completely
satisfied
not because
i believe there isn't something really
fundamentally valuable about
study for its own sake i do i believe
the study for its own sake is
tremendously valuable but i just thought
for my own personality that i would be
frustrated to feel like
okay you know you understood some guy
who lived a thousand years ago better
today
and you helped the five other people in
the world who care about this dude to
understand it better and again i have
tremendous honor and respect for people
who do that all the time
and i work with them in the university
and i'm always telling them like how
valuable and important what they do is
and telling the rest of the world how
important it is but i knew i would be
frustrated with it and law seemed to me
like a domain where you could still try
to crack the codes you could still study
things you could still try to go deep
but where at the end of the day there's
always an output that affects real
people in the real world and you can
either do it really badly and harm
people or you can try to do it better
and perhaps make the world you know suck
a little bit less at the end of the day
so
and i think that's the asper i'm not
saying that every lawyer manages to do
that every day but that is the
aspiration of of law as a legal system
that's why we have a legal system to try
to enable us to arrange our world in a
slightly better way than we'd be able to
arrange it without it so i said let me
try this out and and see if i like it
and on the jd thing that's actually
really funny
if you look at old people's resumes
people who went to law school before the
late 60s it'll say often llb which is
what the degree used to be called used
to be called bachelor of laws and now it
says jd and so you look at that and you
think oh they must have really made law
school a lot tougher and more serious
when they changed it to a jd no it was a
pure marketing exercise what does jd
stand for does some people know the
significance it stands for juris doctor
which means a doctor of laws
and
but the whole thing was a marketing
exercise
by the american bar association in the
late 60s who they were looking at
physicians whose prestige had really
gone up and they had fomo and they
thought you know well you know they go
to school we go to school you know then
again they also learn to like cut up a
cadaver which is not something that a
lawyer a lawyer does and
they said we're going to change the name
of this degree and they pressured all
the law schools to change the llb into a
jd they had a further excuse which was
they said well it's not your first
degree you've already gotten a ba so
therefore your second degree should be
something else but you know if they were
really serious about that they could
have called it a masters but they did it
they called it they called it a doctor
degree
so yeah that that
happened the rebrand
rebrand and upgrade lawyers are really
really good at that you know lawyers are
like
everybody else can't have a monopoly and
we're going to pass a law against
monopolies oh but if you want to
practice law you have to pass the bar
who controls that a bunch of lawyers
they say you have to go to law school
what's that it's a monopoly
doesn't apply to us it doesn't apply to
us that's just a necessary professional
qualification
what other forces or people contributed
to your decision to go to law school or
was that
just from self-study and decision making
on your own were there other inputs that
really
swayed you to
take that path
there definitely were and i would i
would say it started
like a lot of things in my life started
with my dad
who
had himself been a social psychologist
not a lawyer
but was always interested in law and
legal institutions
and
he used to take me actually to the
courthouse in cambridge massachusetts
where i grew up when i was a little kid
just to like watch the court cases
and
you know gave me books about law and i
think he you know was making it pretty
clear that you know he wanted me to at
least look into this as an option
i also uh remember reading as a as a kid
i had a a very kind of 1970s cambridge
massachusetts book which was written for
kids it was a paperback book written on
this
very kind of brown kind of whole wheat
colored paper you know designed to tell
you that it was you know by hippies four
hippies and it was a book for kids and
it was called you were not a short adult
which i think is a funny title for a
book
and the irony is the book kind of did
treat you like a short adult and there
was like a little sidebar with a drawing
and it was about a supreme court case
called tinker against des moines school
district which at the time was a pretty
fresh case
and it was a case where
a family's worth of kids
uh young teens in iowa wore black
armbands to their school to protest the
vietnam war
and they got suspended for it
and they went to court and the supreme
court actually held
that they had a free speech right in
public school
to wear those armbands because the court
said it didn't disrupt the school and
even though they were kids they had a
constitutional free speech right and
that also blew me away like the idea
that kids had rights
seemed incredibly
exciting to me
and no one explained to me at the time
that since i went to a private religious
school i had no rights
but but that was that was the effort
that i had to learn later on
and so that i think also had had a big
influence on me
and then last i would say when i was in
college i took a class on constitutional
law that was offered for college
students
and
there was a terrific teacher a guy
called h.w perry who went on to teach
later at the university of texas as well
and
it was a very intense great group of
just a great group of students in this
class
and we all did constitutional law
together and we were like a little
conlock cult and it was so much fun and
some of my closest friends
are people who were in that class with
me
so it was a really important form of
experience and after that i thought oh
this is what law school is going to be
like all the time which
at its best it was although it wasn't
always like that
i i'd like to ask a bit more about your
dad i see see you you mentioned that he
was
not so
subtly sort of wink-wink
encouraging
the consideration of the legal
profession
and that he also had
a moral to the story
i think you said as he always did
why do you think he wanted to encourage
you
in the direction of law
and
what did it look like
how did he present those morals would he
just say you know
noah i've been thinking and tell you
some random story and say the point of
the story is x or maybe it's not that on
the nose i'd just be curious to know how
he sort of instilled
those those morals
in you
well to answer that question i have to
explain that both of my parents were
social scientists so
their parents were
the people who their their grandparents
had immigrated their parents
you know one one of my one of my
grandfathers went to pharmaceutical
college the other went to a teacher's
college so they went to some kind of
college but my parents were the
generation that like made it to fancy
universities so my parents both had phds
my dad in social psychology and my mom
in political science and so they were
social scientists and they were really
interested in the question of what
causes people to do stuff
and my dad in particular as a social
psychologist
he had done his dissertation with
stanley milgram the guy of the famous
milgram experiment
where you know he managed to get people
to
uh
they didn't they weren't actually doing
this but they thought they were giving
electro shocks to a person behind the
screen and they basically did it because
there was authority there and my dad was
also very influenced by b.f skinner who
was the inventor of
modern behaviorism and so that school of
thought held that you could
produce any behavior you wanted if you
just reinforced it
they just thought the human being is
just a series of inputs and outputs
it's just just classical and operant
conditioning that's it
in internal experience as a black box
ignore it exactly all the way down
black boxing entire this also may
explain why it was so hard for me to do
therapy because it's not like
if you grew up being told that inner
experience is a black box it's kind of
hard to like delve into your inner
experience
so
my dad would never like lay down the
overt meaning because that wouldn't work
what worked was just to repeat the point
enough that you heard it and then if you
behaved appropriately give you positive
reinforcement and if you behave
inappropriately give you negative
reinforcement
and it turns out that is an incredibly
effective way over time
to get your kids to
see the world in a certain kind of way
especially if you add to it you know an
oldest son which i was
who really just worshipped his parents
and in particular his dad
and really really really wanted to make
them
proud of him
as you can imagine a lot of a lot of
fodder there for the therapy later on
too because it's not all fun and games
but um
so that was basically
how he did it and you know i would say
measured by what his objectives were
you could only say that it that it
worked
what were some of the positive and
negative reinforcements if you're
willing to share that were that worked
best for you
well i would say the the positive
reinforcements were mostly affirmation
you know words of affirmation
like what what language might he use
well i'll give you an example that
includes both the positive and the
negative at once and that'll give you
the whole thing in one one sentence
perfect so i let's say i came home from
school with a test and let's say i got a
99 on the test it would say what did you
get on the test i would say i got a 99
yeah i got a 99
and then he would say that's great that
would be the positive affirmation then
there would be a beat one two three
what'd you get wrong
and that was the message very subtly
like yeah you're not really supposed to
get something wrong but if you did
we can learn from it so we do not make
that mistake again
and so that like captured both it's very
subtle
but it was
i was in no doubt about what all the
components of that
meant
um so that i think captures both the
upside and you can imagine
two the the downside which is that you
never really feel
like
you've done enough
because
if you're always looking for positive
reinforcement
you're never going to be perfect and
then you're always going to worry that
you're not going to get that positive
reinforcement
and so that captures potentially a
non-trivial downside
alongside the upside which is like you
then work really hard to you know
do as well as you can on whatever you
see as the task in that in that moment
i think in our
round two i'm going to want to ask you
about your own parenting style
but i'll bookmark that
leave the audience wanting more and i
want to go to
constitution specifically i have a note
here that i would love for you to expand
upon
actually i'll i'll do the lead up
graduated first in his classes harvard
got his doctorate in oxford in just two
years instead of three is that right i
did yeah
reportedly the fast on record yell law
clerked for supreme court then
it's next bullet
served as an adviser to write the iraqi
and tunisian constitutions lived with 50
men in a palace kitchen in iraq for
three months got shot at etc
no i love the i love the etc i think
that was my brilliant girlfriend who put
in the et cetera oh it's great no no the
et cetera sort of what's my appetite for
diving into this
please
tell the story of
the palace kitchen as a way to to segue
into conversation about the constitution
or constitutions in general
the way i found myself
sleeping on the floor of the palace
kitchen
in the republican palace in baghdad with
50 other
very dirty men
um
was that after 9 11
i
took advantage of the fact that i had
studied
islamic political philosophy to write a
book
arguing for how we as americans could
change our attitude
towards the possibility of democracy in
the middle east
what was the title of that book that was
called after jihad america and the
struggle for islamic democracy and i
wasn't saying that islamic democracy
would necessarily work but i was saying
no one's ever really tried it and we
americans have never encouraged anybody
to try it
and that was before anyone thought we
should invade iraq
and create a circumstance where
democracy might be able to emerge at
least that was the aspiration but when
the u.s then did invade iraq
there was an immediate rush within the
actually was the defense department
to see if they could find somebody who
had studied islam could speak arabic and
was an expert in constitutional law
to go and work on the possible
development of a constitution for iraq
that would be democratic
and the bottom line is there just
weren't very many people with that
particular skill set you know in fact
you know there may only have been a
handful and the others didn't want to go
maybe because they were smarter than i
was about what was likely to happen next
but i was you know 32 years old and
when they asked me my first reaction was
to say to the
defense department official who called
me listen i just want you to know i'm
very honored to be asked i'd love to go
but you're not going to want me because
i worked for al gore
litigating in the bush v gore
you know 2000 election fight which was
just a few years prior to that and
you're going to find that out when you
you know look me up and i don't want to
waste your time and the guy was um was a
very impressive guy called ryan henry a
former top gun pilot
very straight shooter and he was
actually offended
and he said to me you know young man
this is not a political appointment we
don't care what your politics are
you know just go and do the job and i
was thrilled and
too naive to realize that was just a
form of words um
i mean it may not have been from him i
think he may have meant it sincerely
it's just that you know in the reality
once you got there it turned out it was
of course profoundly political but in
any case i was like great sign me up and
i went
and i thought it was especially a good
opportunity because since i wasn't a
republican i wasn't going to be trying
to advance within the ranks of the bush
administration so i would just get there
be on the ground and call it like it is
which is in fact what i ended up doing
and so we got to baghdad about two days
or three days after the statue of saddam
had come down since april of 2003 and it
was as you can imagine just beyond a
wreck and we literally camped out in the
republican palace and the kitchen was
big
it turned out maybe the kitchen was a
poor choice because there were vents in
the ground and enormous bugs were
constantly coming up out of there
um
there and we we like put down our you
know our sleeping bags and then
eventually we got these little cots and
we would try to like put mosquito nets
over ourselves it was about as the
summer progressed it got to be about
like 125 degrees in the shade it never
really cooled down in the republican
palace you don't even want to know about
the bathroom arrangements
you know your listeners might be a
little squeamish around that that one or
they should be if they knew what it was
like
and it was like a fascinating experience
because in the cart right next to me was
a full bird colonel
who was on his way to becoming promoted
to to being a to being a general
and he liked to make fun of me and he
was not much older than i was he was
probably five or six years older than i
was but he liked to call me sun
since he was about six inches taller
than i was and a very you know
distinguished uh african-american he was
getting a lot of pleasure out of this
and i remember the moment when
so they issued us all civilians were
issued with um
with the up-to-date flak jackets but the
up-to-date flak jackets had a slot where
you were supposed to put in a ceramic
plate that would stop bullets and they
ran out of ceramic plates
which was appropriate because we were
not high priority personnel the ceramic
plates needed to go to the front line
soldiers so we had these vests without
the plates
and so i would wear that and then so
this this gentleman's desert uh palace
couture i guess exactly yeah literally
and he said to me son you know what's
going to happen to you wearing that vest
and i said no sir i just instinctively
called him sir
and he was the kind of guy who inspired
that
and he said
well when you get shot with a 9 you know
nine millimeter bullet that will slow it
down just enough
that when it comes through you it'll be
at a nice easy pace
and then it'll hit the back wall of the
vest
and it'll bounce back in it'll bounce
around a few more times
and i you know you can see the blood
draining from my face
and then i said to him well what will
happen if i'm not wearing the vest he
says
son then that nine will go right through
you and i was like okay that doesn't
sound good either he's like believe me
it would be less bad
so i took off the vest and i literally
gave it to someone else who had access
to a ceramic to a ceramic plate but not
to the vest
and let him use it and that was the last
time i wore a vest then i just walked
around iraq you know for the next couple
of months
basically wearing um
civilian clothes which after all is what
the iraqis we were meeting with were
wearing you know i mean you meet with
people it does not it's not actually a
good look if you're all dressed up in
battle rattle and they're just standing
there um it sends exactly the wrong the
wrong message um and so that was how i
got there and it was a fascinating
fascinating experience because i
basically talked to iraqis from all
walks of life left the green zone every
day
originally i would just take a cab i
would literally go out in front of what
they later came to call the assassins
gate we didn't call it that at the time
and just hail a cab
and then at some point i started taking
cars from them from the motor pool when
i got to know my way around a little bit
better
and this was before the really bad
terrorism began it started very shortly
thereafter but i was able to travel over
the country and talk to many people from
different walks of life and i learned a
lot about what people were thinking
about their constitutional aspirations
and i learned a lot about what not to do
when you invade another country i mean
everything that you could possibly know
about what not to do i learned because
we did every single thing that you
should not do when you invade another
country and most of the mistakes we made
in iraq we made up front in that very
early period of time
well that's a cliffhanger i do
ultimately want to come back to what was
done in that palace kitchen but what
were
if we did sort of an 80 20 analysis on
the
things not to do the
the things that one should be advised
against doing when invading a country
what would be at the top of of the list
from that experience that you observed
the number one thing is
failing to the number one screw-up is
failing to tell everybody in the country
who's in charge and proving that you're
in charge
we never did it and the iraqis were
literally
super confused
they expected there had been coup
d'etats in the past it had been a while
but they knew what would happen right
some would go on the on the loudspeakers
with trucks and say you know there's a
new president everyone stay home
then the next day they'd be like there's
a new president everyone show up at work
and everyone understood that that was
like not a request but a direct order
we arrived
and for weeks and weeks nobody knew who
was in charge
was there a civilian in charge was there
a general in charge
nobody knew who was in charge and in
fact at one point on the street in iraq
someone actually asked me a group of
people actually asked me first they
wanted to know when is the electricity
coming back on i didn't know
when's the water going to start running
again i didn't know when does school
reopen i didn't know and then someone
said to me who's the government
and i was like shocked by this question
i mean i understood the words it was
only two words in arabic but i i was
like what are they even asking me and
then i realized what they were saying
and i said oh you know ambassador
bremmer is the government because by
then
uh president bush had sent out
ambassador bremer and they were like
we've never heard of that guy
and i realized that in that moment that
you know we had really massively screwed
it up so first thing you need to do is
tell people who's in charge and the
second thing is you have to prove that
it's real
and that means you have to have
either police
or soldiers on the street and if you
don't have enough of your own which we
didn't you need to use the local people
so we should have had the local police
or the local military even if they
weren't trustworthy
out there on the streets communicating
that someone was in charge and if no
one's in charge
then you're not safe as an ordinary
person and if you're not safe
you need someone who's going to protect
you
and if you're not safe and need some to
protect you you're going to look for
what your local affiliation is in your
neighborhood and you're going to break
into groups you're like you're creating
a situation we created a situation
that's like if you're in a terrible
neighborhood where there are gangs
and there's a good person who doesn't
want to join a gang but there's no one
else to protect them you have to join a
gang because you need protection from
somebody because the state's not
protecting you and that is the situation
that we created
to double click on that even if they're
not trustworthy part is that because is
that superior to not having them on the
street because you need
at the very least security theater much
like
some of what happens say with the tsa
not just like the tsa very important
but there are some things that you know
sort of uh what is it edge cases make
bad case lock whatever you see some
pretty wild things but is it just to
create the perception of
a central
competent
power that has put
law enforcement on the street is that
why you say even if they're not
trustworthy
yeah you can't create a situation where
people think there's anarchy right and
so even if
some of the people you were ordering to
do things
might have occasionally backslid
you know you'd have to take that risk
if your only other option is not having
anybody i mean if we had invaded iraq
with 600 000 troops the way that colin
powell thought we should we would have
had enough of our own soldiers on the
streets to do that but we didn't do that
we invaded with a very small force
and when baghdad fell the total number
of us troops in the country was probably
fewer than a hundred thousand
and
in baghdad it was way beneath that so we
just didn't have the bodies and so you
could drive for you know what felt like
an hour and a half through the city and
not see any representative of any
authority no cops no u.s troops and
certainly no iraqi troops so you do need
to create that perception and
obviously it has to be some reality
behind it because people will try to
test it
but the perception is crucial because if
people think that there's nobody in
charge they get scared
and they're correct to be scared
let's go back to the
palace you have
you've taken off your flak jacket aka
ricochet death machine
you're in civilian clothing
and
you are working on
constitutions
as as i understand it if i'm getting
that wrong please correct me but let's
start with
basic basic basics
what is a constitution and then if you
could pick up the story
a constitution is
a blueprint
for
how any group of people
wants to govern itself
and it requires
collective agreement not of necessarily
every person but of let's say a super
majority of the people a lot more than
half
and
because human beings you know can't get
together in the hundreds of thousands to
do that what that practically means is
that a smaller number of people
have to propose the agreement and then
have it validated by the more general
public
and if you're trying to build one of
these things from scratch
the first thing you need to know is
what people could credibly speak on
behalf
of the general public
what group of people could propose
something that would have a chance of
actually being accepted
so you need the right people at the
table
and
those also have to be people who think
in the end that they have more to gain
by an agreement
than they do by failing to agree
and if they
don't have more to gain by it then
they're not going to agree and then
you're going to get a kind of a collapse
i would just add one footnote to that
which i learned the hard way in iraq
which is
you can't really do this
if you don't have order
if your situation is to use the amazing
argentinian spanish word that you
already taught me it's kilombo right
yeah exactly that is a perfect example
of a kilumbo yes
if you have kilombo you there's no
chance that you're going to be able to
build a constitution
you might get a peace treaty to stop
people from killing each other and then
you could talk about a constitution when
you have order but now is that just
because maslow's hierarchy of needs
you're
you're sort of skipping a few rungs is
that why you can't do it
that's definitely part of it but i also
think it's that to reach an agreement
about how we're going to govern
ourselves collectively we have to have
some general idea
of how power is arranged in our society
we have to really know who are the
powerful people who are the weaker
people what are the different capacities
of different groups to get what they
want
and
if i think that tomorrow you're gonna
come with your neighbors
and shoot me
then again we might be able to reach a
peace treaty but i'm not going to trust
you enough to reach an agreement about
how we would collectively govern in the
long run and if you also simultaneously
think that i might do that to you we're
both like eyeing each other and trying
to gauge
what the potential violence might be
that we would do we're not in a place
where we can realistically negotiate a
plan for how we're going to self-govern
over a long period of time
i do think the hierarchy of needs is
relevant there for sure and safety is of
course
right up there alongside you know food
shelter
you know and water
and when you have a breakdown of safety
there's a
extreme uncertainty that follows and you
can't negotiate against the backdrop of
that much uncertainty in a realistic way
how do you draft a constitution
when you when you have
let's just say you you are not operating
in a worst case environment
how do you approach drafting a
constitution how did you approach
drafting constitution
almost no constitutions in the modern
world are totally invented from scratch
right it's the same would be if like you
were doing a startup
you know you probably want to invent
your corporate culture from scratch and
you probably want to invent a new
product but you don't want to invent the
corporate form of government from
scratch
there are other people who have done
that and you can pick and choose
from a kind of menu of options and then
tweak it to your particular set of
interests and that's how most
constitutions in the modern world are
done
even when james madison was trying to
originate modern constitutionalism he
looked to the ancient world to the
constitutions of the ancient world as
models and he also looked to
the the british constitution even though
that one wasn't a single written
constitution
he still looked to aspects of it so you
know the idea for example that there
would be a legislative branch and an
executive branch in a judicial branch
was not one that was just being invented
then they were borrowing that that was
an idea that had been around
so you do some borrowing from other
constitutions
and
then you have to answer some a handful
of really core definitional questions
you know
what are the powerful entities within
the society
how can they best trust each other
how should the public be represented do
you want to have a parliament that
represents everybody and then only have
the executive be derived from the
parliament the way you would in a
parliamentary system do you want a
president who's independently elected by
all of the people
how much power should the president have
relative to the parliament
those are the kinds of sort of second
order questions that you want to try to
answer and you want to answer those
questions not
in the abstract but concretely by
reference to what the different groups
of people in the society want what their
beliefs are and above all how they could
agree to live together in a way that
will share power and ideally where
they'll be able to alternate power
between different groups of people
because if you can alternate power you
get a lot of good incentives for
everyone treating everybody relatively
well
if i think that my group is gonna have
all the power all the time there's just
no reason to treat your group well i
might as well expropriate you take away
your property i might enslave you treat
you as second-class citizens
but if i think that you know in the next
election you're going to be ruling over
me
then i'm not going to do that to you
you know we have a kind of like
you know we have a standoff and that
standoff enables us to say okay let's
all agree on a system that it has
equality and rights because sometimes
i'm in charge and sometimes you're in
charge and i'd rather be equal when
you're in charge and you'd rather be
equal when i'm in charge
this might be a strange question but are
there any particular
constitutions or
the equivalent of a constitution past
or present that you find particularly
beautiful
or elegant
the south african constitution that came
into being
after nelson mandela was let out of
prison and the anc
came to power and negotiated a
constitution
with the former apartheid regime
is at least as written a kind of best
practices modern constitution
not that it was perfect
because
it guaranteed
a lot of rights which is good
but it also
took recognition of
the economic realities of south africa
and what i mean by that is that the anc
they knew that the distribution of
wealth in the country was fundamentally
unjust after generations of apartheid
and before that imperialism
but they also knew they didn't want
white south africans with their capital
and know-how
to flee the country
as had happened for example in zimbabwe
when it was no longer rhodesia
and so they knew that they had to
guarantee
the rights
of the white minority
even at the expense of not
redistributing wealth in a way that
would have been fair
so as to enable the country to develop
and evolve
and you know if you talk to contemporary
south africans they will be very honest
with you about the failings
of
this post-apartheid order as well it's
not as though life in south africa is
perfect by any stretch of the
imagination they've been plagued by a
whole range of problems including
serious corruption
but
what they did succeed in doing is that
there was not
massive capital flight
there was not
significant violent retribution by
formerly oppressed
africans against the white population
there was not civil war
those are incredible accomplishments
there was a certain amount of truth and
reconciliation achieved through truth
and reconciliation commission
and so that constitutional order which
was a very carefully subtly negotiated
one over a longish period of time
actually is in many ways extremely
beautiful again notwithstanding that in
the real world it didn't solve every
problem that's the other thing to keep
in mind about constitutions they can't
solve every problem you know if your
society has say high unemployment
you can have a beautiful constitution
you can't solve the unemployment that
way you know tunisia has that tunisia
drafted a really elegant constitution
not perfect but really elegant
constitution after the arab spring and
after they transitioned to becoming a
kind of a democracy
but the arab spring started because
people were mad that they had no jobs
to oversimplify
and after the democratic government came
into play they still didn't have jobs
right and they were still mad because
you can have a perfect constitution it
doesn't solve the fundamental economic
you know struggles that uh the society
faces constitutions can't do everything
i'd like to
broaden the way well really have you
brought in the way
i'm not gonna do much heavy lifting here
think about constitutions and i also
want to say because
she was mentioned earlier i i need to
thank
your girlfriend for a tremendous
job of sending lots of
well-prepared and juicy
jumping off points for exploration so i
want to give her a special shout out
because
it's it's it's been tremendously helpful
and exciting for me to have that in my
back pocket
so here here is one i'll read this and
then i'd love for you to elaborate
because
i think it'll be of interest to a lot of
listeners to know what will happen in
crypto you need to know how
constitutions work and how they fail
please elaborate
so echoing your your point of i'm
tremendously grateful to her for
teaching me how to how to do this and
for making me sound a lot more
interesting than i actually am
so here's how a crypto platform
is like a constitution
every single
cryptocurrency
is based on an agreement
among the participants
in the platform that underlies the
currency
about how they're going to interact with
each other
how they're going to distribute power
who's going to be able to decide
how many of the coins if it's a
cryptocurrency how many of the coins are
produced
how they're going to be distributed
how the blockchain is going to take
account of that distributive process
how decisions are going to be made when
there's a conflict
among
different participants
in the platform
who is capable of forking the platform
so that you get a different
platform that comes into existence which
you know in the world of constitutions
we would call a revolution or a civil
war
those are the kinds of questions that
ask
how are we this group of people going to
govern ourselves
in this common enterprise that we have
and what you have again is that beneath
every crypto platform is a literal
agreement
words written on paper
that describe what the rules are going
to be
and then what's distinctive about the
crypto context is that those rules are
then instantiated
in
a series of algorithmic programs
that facilitate
making sure that you do follow the rules
and then double check that or triple
check that or any larger number than
that check that through the blockchain
and so when a platform
goes well it's because the participants
in the platform are following those
rules and are in agreement with those
rules
and when it goes south
it's because there's a dispute over
those rules
there can be a break over those rules
and at that point people might abandon
the platform or they might fork and you
know create an alternate platform
or they might actually get into a
literal fight over what what's supposed
to happen
and i should say just you know to give a
lot of credit where it's due
someone you've had as a guest on your
podcast and i even managed to get them
onto my podcast which was i thought a
minor miracle i'm not not surprisingly
be on yours um vitalik bhutaran who's
one of the core figures in the founding
of ethereum
has
got a terrific essay on his own blog
about legitimacy the concept of
legitimacy
on
uh in the crypto world and and on the
blockchain that really helped me think
these things
through and really made me realize the
depth of the of the similarities
because legitimacy is a property
of constitutional systems when they're
working well it's the property that
everybody who's in the system can
predict with a high degree of
probability how things are going to
proceed
and everyone thinks that's basically
fair
and if you withdraw either of those
components either the predictability or
the fairness
the constitutional system will collapse
and the same turns out to be true of a
crypto platform
vitalik is a
smart cookie oh wow
to make it
to make a huge understatement
are there any other
thinkers and or practitioners if that
makes sense they could be computer
scientists they could
participate in some other capacity but
any thinkers or practitioners in the
in the space of blockchain
cryptocurrency who you
find interesting outside of vitalik
i mean there are many and i i am often
in the position of of just trying to
understand what the new innovations are
that people are are coming up with in in
real time i think one reason that i'm so
drawn to vitalik is that he does
something a lot of others don't do he
spends a lot of his time explaining
stuff
in terms that are accessible to people
who aren't already on the inside and not
infrequently i'll read something by
somebody else and i think there's
something really important i don't
totally get it then i go to vitalik's
blog and i see him engaging with it he
actually explains it and explaining
things well it's a different skill from
inventing stuff and he happens to have
both of those skills so that's yeah he's
like nikola tesla and bill nye the
science guy wrapped into one
really it's really true
i'd like to
we're going to bounce around a little
bit but if this is all interrelated
how does understanding of history allow
you to be a futurist
i think in some way
all of us every day are trying to figure
out what's going to happen tomorrow and
you know that's true in an obvious way
if you're investing in something you
want to know what's going to happen to
that asset tomorrow it's true though if
you're picking a job it's true if you're
choosing a relationship
it's true in some way if you're just
getting up in the morning that you're
trying to predict what's going to happen
in the world and at the most fundamental
level we do that by looking at the past
and you know there's always the constant
reminder past performance does not
guarantee future results and that's true
but the reason we have to bother to say
that is that the past is our first guide
to figuring out what's happened
what i like to do is to try to see
the way that crises and problems and
challenges have played out in the past
and then ask whether a change in our
arrangements
is actually going to fix those things
or is actually inheriting those problems
and where this is especially useful i
think is in environments where we know
that we're facing some disruptive
technology or some disruptive change
so
i don't know take an example take airbnb
you know airbnb self-consciously set out
to disrupt the hotel industry and they
did it
if you're trying to figure out when
airbnb was getting started what
challenges will they face one thing to
do would be to look to the history of
the hotel industry and ask what was the
biggest challenge the hotel industry
faced in say the 20th century and the
answer turns out to be racial
discrimination
right you know for much of the 20th
century in the united states hotels were
racially segregated in large parts of
the country
integrating the process of integration
had a lot to do with hotels
you know some folks may have seen the
the movie the green book
which literally refers to the physical
book that african americans had to carry
with them when they were traveling
around the segregated south so they
would know
where they were legally allowed to stay
right so the process that shows you you
know the fundamentally you know
transformative nature of desegregation
so now you're airbnb you've disrupted
this industry
it would have been plausible and easy to
predict i would even say maybe easy is
too strong a word but possible to
predict that airbnb would face
challenges around racial discrimination
by their uh users both by people who
were renting out airbnbs and people who
rent them
because they were inheriting this
industry
and so the social challenge that had
faced that industry wasn't going to
disappear
when it passed into this new industry
and i think that's a nice concrete
example of how looking at the past can
actually help you make predictions about
what the challenges are going to be in
the future and then those are actionable
predictions you know then you can say
well if we're going to design a
disruptive technology for hotels we need
to build in
protections against forms of racial
discrimination that we think are wrong
and you know airbnb eventually got
around to that and did do that
but that's an example of where you can
look to the past and you can learn a lot
about what's
going to happen in the future another
concrete example would be
political polarization which is
something that i think all of us have
had to spend a lot of time thinking
about over the last you know five or six
years and it doesn't really matter
whether you're thinking of it because
you care about politics or you're
thinking about it because you know your
business is a business that inevitably
interacts with the public and the public
is polarized
you know i mean we live in a world where
it's not just the politicians we vote
for who are becoming polarized but our
views about
science are polarized interviews about
medicine or polarizing our brand choices
are increasingly polarized in a range of
ways so we all have to think about it
one way or another
there you can look back to past
instances of polarization in our society
which have in many cases been
devastating and you can look at the ways
we crawled out of those
and you can take advantage of the things
that worked when we did crawl out
primarily forms of compromise
and forms of recognition of the other
side as having more in common than
than actually separates us
and you can try to self-consciously
build on those models
to try to figure out how to make the
future somewhat better than it otherwise
might be and you can also look at when
we failed
you know the civil war being the big
example where our polarization just
failed
and we split in two and you can try to
avoid the problems that helped create
that failure
i have so many questions
i feel like
i feel like a little kid who's like
so excited just like jumping up and down
trying to like tug at a parent's sleeve
to get attention because they just
they can't contain
they can't contain what they want to say
i i'm just going to try to spit these
out one at a time all right so the first
is
do you have any recommendations for
books they could be your own
for people who want to study
and i'm not sure
exactly how to separate or define these
things but
the creation of governance
and maybe state building uh the name
francis fukuyama comes to mind because a
friend has recommended his work over and
over and over again
i know that patrick collison when he was
on this podcast
we talked about
i believe i'm getting the name right lee
kuan yew am i getting that right
who transformed singapore into what it
is i mean just an incredible incredible
story
but for people who are
for
practical purposes trying to get a grasp
of this
and and i think about for
instance blockchain and dows right these
uh these these new organizations
man oh man our lawyer's gonna be busy
but putting that aside there are people
right now who are
crafting constitutions right they're
they're
doing this
with some frequency especially with the
experimentation
that is happening on mass right now if
you just look at say nfts and so on
which
as much as people might ridicule them
for the surface level appearance of just
like silly jpegs
there's there's a lot underneath that
that i think is
deeply interesting and will prove
valuable
uh any books you might recommend for
people who want to roll up their sleeves
as possible crafters of constitutions
and governments
yeah so i i agree with you that francis
fukuyama frank fukuyama is amazing on
this he's especially good
also on how things fall apart um he's
very very good on what he calls decay as
well as being very very good on
on the building of such institutions i
actually uh had him on my podcast
recently and
he's just totally spectacular on this
and so he and his work is also
even though he's a very scholarly person
the books are written in a very readable
and accessible way
is there a starting point you might
recommend
of his books
yeah i mean i think
it's interesting one of his most recent
books is this kind of
grand grand book political order and
political decay
it's an amazing book it's not a short
book
and i don't know if i would recommend it
the whole book as an introduction
but i think you could read the first
part of the book which is sort of a book
on its own and get a really good account
of how political order comes into
existence
and then you know take a deep breath and
then read the second part of the book
about how it all falls apart on the
other side um so i think if i was going
to pick one of frank's book it would be
it would be political order and
political decay
another book which is a bit shorter
and which i have found incredibly
helpful
uh for me
is a book called democracy and the
market
and it's by a
polish born political scientist whose
name is adam chavorski and i'll spell
his last name because it's
not how it sounds uh it's
p r z
e w
o
o-r-s-k-i
shavor it pronounced shivorsky because
that's how languages roll um
and chavorsky is just also just a
completely fascinating fascinating
person who was very influential on me
when i was trying to figure out how you
design governments and one of the things
that he talks about in democracy in the
market
is about how the creation of democracies
is intertwined with the operation of
capitalism
you know we when we study in school how
democracies come into existence we
usually don't really think about how
they interface with the organization of
capital
but actually it's centrally important um
this sort of the big alexander hamilton
point that alexander hamilton was always
making when the u.s was founded james
madison had designed the constitution
and hamilton basically said
i don't really care that much about the
constitution i care about the financial
markets
and he literally walked out of the
constitutional convention halfway
through he was like whatever it doesn't
matter i don't care but then once there
was a government
he devoted everything he had as
secretary of treasury to basically
creating the bond markets
and he did it because he thought that
by creating a bond market the government
would have somebody it could borrow from
it would then be able to raise the
capital to do stuff and then it would be
effective
then it could have a navy and you know
then it could eventually
have infrastructure you know you need to
borrow money to do this stuff so he
needed to create a bond market so there
would be a way to actually do that
and he also wanted the government to
need to borrow money so that there would
be a bond market so that wealth could be
created so that you could have capital
markets so that they could build
manufacturing
madison didn't care about any of this
and in fact he opposed most of it which
was in retrospect hopelessly naive you
know he was like this virginian
gentleman with enslaved people working
for him on a plantation which was not
the future let's just say with respect
to you know the economy of the united
states
so shivorsky is like great on that and i
think his book and it's a short book and
very readable even though it's not a new
book um he's got newer books but that's
the one that i come back to uh i don't i
don't need new i kind of like old if the
principles still hold which it sounds
like i think i think that book really
really really does
schworsky you know the czech and polish
they're like the opposite of hawaiian
right like the hawaiians love vowels and
man oh man do you like the the poles in
the chat just love consonants they
really do they hit those they they hate
themselves from vowels
uh
you know i'm debating where to go next
here
i could talk about the dos a little bit
if you want i didn't answer that part of
the question
yes please
yeah so just to mention them
so
daos and it stands for decentralized
autonomous organization
are
a kind of very interesting promising
still i would say i'll say flavor of the
month
kind of organization
that operates on the blockchain
that is supposed to and when it works
well does
allow for collective
decision making
quote unquote from the bottom up
that is to say they do not have a
central authority in the middle they
don't have the centralized decision
maker that most constitutional systems
ordinarily do have they don't have as it
were a president or a prime minister and
they also don't have a hierarchical
system
where like a staff or a board of
directors
that's elected makes decisions about
where the assets of the organization
should be put instead the idea is that
everybody collectively who's in the dao
can vote on how resources are going to
be allocated so they're kind of a strong
wisdom of crowds
idea the idea is that if the collective
makes the decisions the odds are better
that the collectivity will make good
decisions and that also tells you what
the value proposition is to invest in a
deo is in a way to bet on the wisdom of
the crowd and not just the wisdom but on
the collective capacity of the crowd to
work together
and
that's a fascinating bet
and you can see from that formulation
why it's very attractive and also why
it's a bit utopian and why some people
remain skeptical of the capacities of
daos to do
all of the different things that people
hope that they'll be able to do because
again talk about using history to
protect the future if you look at the
history of
decentralized decision-making
organizations
they've often existed
guilds
some labor unions depending on how they
were organized they can do certain
things really well they can coordinate
certain things really well but there's
certain kinds of decision making that
historically are really hard to make in
a decentralized way so when you're
engaged in a conflict with another
entity when you're engaged in direct
competition with another entity when you
need to coordinate action beyond the
initial purposes and evolve your
purposes
historically it's been really hard for
decentralized organizations to pull that
off so you want to pick and choose
carefully with respect to
what the dao's purposes are and what its
objectives are and that
should be helpful to the process of
deciding you know how how do you want to
be involved in the dao and what will it
be capable of accomplishing
so someone in my household may or may
not be me
may have become somewhat i don't want to
say infatuated that's not the right word
but
obsessed with researching a lot of the
the kind of nitty gritty aspects of
of daos and
dao's i like saying dow just because it
makes me think about the
which i think is
metaphorically sort of uh appealing
excellent branding no question
but the the in part because
i think of
the fact that not all iterations need to
work right but you will have massive
trial and error over a compressed time
period which which is what gets so
exciting to me because if you want to
create
a new corporate entity structure outside
of c-corp s corp llc like good luck i
mean it's just going to take you forever
to get there
but in the case of a dao you can really
experiment and
in a sense split test even though it
might be two competing parties trying to
collectively acquire assets let's just
say and there are some that have become
really interesting and really powerful
like flamingo would be an example
and
i don't know if this has been done yet
maybe it has and i'm just getting up to
speed on these things but for instance i
have a foundation
and the foundation funds all sorts of
research into
say psychedelic therapeutics and so on
for different
supposedly intractable psychiatric
conditions although i would i would veto
the intractable part at this point
and it's a real pain in the ass to deal
with the foundation as a tiny tiny team
there's a lot of paperwork
all due respect to lawyers lots of
lawyers lots of hours
lots of filings lots of
to this day
signatures of multiple people if i want
to accept
say donations from other people capital
from other people to fun projects
there are
various types of
red tape and headache involved but you
know if there were the potential of
bringing people into a dow
collectively contributing
and then having some type of tax
efficient slash
tax deductible
approach to donating to
non-profit ventures
my god that would solve a huge pain
point for me i don't like being the
centralized control point for this right
and i guess that's that's more of a rant
than a question but are there any
particular
experiments that you're looking forward
to seeing or hoping to see
in this space doesn't have to be dao
specific but it could be more broadly
speaking
i mean you just named a fascinating one
so
to the extent that one of the things
that these
dow is on i'll use your terminology
sorry i might be corrupting you no no
it's good um that they do is they
facilitate decision making about
assigning assets not only acquisition of
assets but assignment of assets
i'm really fascinated to see which
things they'll succeed in doing really
well
and which things they'll do less well at
so take for example you know a
foundation
where you want to do good in the world
but where you want to devote those
assets
is you know a question that reasonable
people could differ about
you know part of it will be would the
people who participated in that
decentralized autonomous organization be
people who shared your world view enough
that you would think that was good so
you know if there are people who if it's
listeners to your podcast and people who
read your books there might be enough
overlap that they would
want to for example
promote
psychedelic research which is having
these extraordinary successes
today
i don't know if they would have thought
that 10 years ago when you started doing
this
right or not i mean that's one of the
interesting questions could a collective
be as forward-looking and as willing to
take certain kind of risks as you were
on this issue
we do know that when it comes to
certain kinds of factual questions
crowds do really well so if you ask a
factual question the collectivity might
be great
when it comes to predictive questions
it's a more mixed bag right
if the if the crowd always did well on
that the markets would always make the
correct predictions they don't always
make the correct predictions right
because because groups are subject
they're they're human beings behind
there and they're subject to all of the
the biases and uncertainties that are
that are out there you know if the
people who bought into the dao were
representative of the world
you know you might have like a huge
number of people who were adherents to
the chinese communist party and another
large number of people who were deeply
committed believing muslims i'm just
thinking of you know groups that have a
billion more than a billion people you
know and they might fight it out within
the dao about what they want to
invest in and so you know again i think
it's very much about the purpose and who
the participants are so those are the
kinds of experiments i think that are
gonna as you say in an iterated way show
us what these things are really good at
and show us where these things run into
some of the limitations of human
coordinated behavior
absolutely and you know i was thinking
of
your comments earlier on
attempts to create
i don't want to slide it with
utopian implying naive necessarily but
in some cases they were attempts at
creating
non-hierarchical flat
consensus-based
communal living right almost every one
of those experiments has failed
as far as i can tell yeah
typically in spectacular fashion like
they're they're these catalyzing events
and i remember at some point i can't
remember who wrote this initially i
think it was actually a very old book
maybe in the 1980s on terrorism believe
it or not
but
that every movement attracts crusaders
criminals and crazies it's like the
three c's
and also just observing
uh or studying history you see that
within if there is a void of
concentrated power
eventually someone will come in to
capture that void or occupy that void if
that makes sense right yeah and
within
our sort of historical frameworks
that could be done what's also
interesting to me about dows and not
just dao's but blockchain in general is
that
if you have
it is supposedly
uh well if you set it up such that you
have uneditable smart contracts right
that the social engineering
that one could impose to fill
that void
is perhaps more difficult
right but at the same time you have to
really get the thinking right up front
because you could perpetuate bugs all
over the place uh i don't know if you
have any
if that prompts any thoughts
yeah i mean i think you're making a
really deep point about the idea of the
upfront uneditable contract
right i mean smart contracts are awesome
because of their enforcement capacities
right what makes a smart contract better
than other kinds of contracts is it's as
close to self-enforcing as you can get
you don't need a whole legal system to
do the enforcement side of it
what and that's what makes it smart
but the uneditable part means it also
has a feature that no real world
contract otherwise ever has pretty much
which is that it's uneditable
right you can't evolve it right if you
and i ordinarily sign a contract as
simple as like
you know tim needs me to um
you know to cut cut the grass on his
lawn
and i start doing it
and then you're like you know what i
it's been raining a lot lately i want
you to come a little more often
or
you know and i say well you know it's
true but when it rains a lot i have a
lot of other customers i need to charge
you a little more
when it's just rained
right it's this most minor tweak you
could possibly imagine in a contract and
we do it every single day and almost all
of the contracts that we're engaged in
have some kind of flow like that in them
and you can't do that with an uneditable
contract
so one of the benefits of contracting
relationships is that they tend to be
evolving
relationships in a way that's beneficial
to both parties
and so you lose some of that capacity in
an uneditable contract sure you can
invent a new one that's a variant on it
so it's not impossible to solve this
and maybe over time we'll even see
algorithmically developing contracts
where the contracts themselves love the
capacity for internal evolution
so i don't want to say that it's not
solvable i i imagine it probably is
solvable and maybe
people are already in fact now that i
say it must be that people are already
trying to do this
but then it's not uneditable
and so
you know i guess
what strikes me about it is that
the smartness of smart contracts needs
eventually to extend not only to the
enforcement side of it but also to the
flexibility side of it in order to
capture some of the benefits of what
makes the contract
such a powerful tool in our universe and
by the way it's not an accident the
contracts are behind partnerships and
they're behind business transactions and
they're also the central metaphor behind
constitutions which are in some way the
social contract that's that's a contract
i can't think of a better place to segue
back as promised to the broken
constitution
lincoln slavery and the re-founding of
america
why did you write this book
like a lot of us
i have been struggling in the last few
years with a question that is actually
really old but maybe it's to our
detriment that we haven't thought about
it as much
namely is our
whole system
from the constitution on
fundamentally
ruined
by
having racism and slavery
in its dna from the start
or
can we be
a lot more optimistic about our
capacities
as a country by virtue of progress
that we've made
since our declaration of independence
was written by a slaveholder
and our constitution was drafted
primarily by a slaveholder at a
convention where slaveholding states had
a huge amount of influence
and you know that question's been
on the front page of a lot of newspapers
it's
being debated in terms of what we teach
our kids in schools and it's it's a
fundamental identity question for us
as a country
and it matters
and here i am i'm a constitutions guy
and i had written a book about james
madison you know one of the lead
drafters of the constitution the lead
drafter of the constitution really its
inventor who was himself a slaveholder
so i thought about the question in terms
of him
but i hadn't really thought about that
question in terms of
what we did
when we changed when we broke it all
down
and when we smashed
the constitution and the country
in the civil war
and i think the depth of disagreement
and polarization
over the last handful of years
really also made me think
you know how bad is our situation
relative to the situation then
and i wanted to find out answers to
those questions and that's why i started
doing the research for the book and the
book is my attempt to answer those
questions
please say more can you provide some
more
some more context yeah i'll give you my
my sort of top-of-the-line
answer to the question
via
a story
and in all of my books i try to have a
story because that's how i think i can
make sense out of
bigger and more abstract ideas better if
i do them through the human beings who
actually thought them and lincoln's got
a hell of a story
it seems like that's also how good abba
don taught you also it is
you're absolutely right that is a very
powerful insight and you can you can
send me the bill for the session
and i i will i will gladly pair that is
an excellent and correct correct insight
into my uh
my formation of my character
so
lincoln's story is fascinating because
lincoln was a compromiser his whole life
he associated himself with the political
party of compromise which was the whig
party which was the party that
repeatedly saved
the united states from breaking into
pieces
in
1830
and again in the 1840s and again in the
1850s
and
every time the country was about to fall
apart over the slavery question
really
the wigs
the wigs saved it henry clay was the
called the great compromiser he was the
founder of the wig party and he was
lincoln's idol and he was lincoln's god
and even when he was elected president
lincoln was still trying to compromise
so you know when you go to the lincoln
memorial you see
two speeches written on the wall on the
two sides of lincoln one is
his gettysburg address
and the other is his second inaugural no
one ever mentions lincoln's first
inaugural
and it turns out there's a reason for
that which i discovered when i read
lincoln's first inaugural which is that
the opening sentence says basically
i have no interest or intention in ever
interfering with slavery slavery is in
the constitution it's permanent if you
southerners will just reverse this whole
secession business we will make sure you
have your slaves forever
so that's the guy's story running up to
the civil war
and you know he said that and then
you know in just a month
shots were fired and the war began
and lincoln realized the constitution
was well and truly broken
and he decided to break the constitution
further
in order to make it into something new
hard fork
yeah hard fork the hardest possible fork
exactly it doesn't get harder than that
right sending the troops is the hardest
fork you could possibly have
and
actually i mean i to go even further all
of those compromises were founded in the
original compromise which and we have to
be honest about this was a compromise
over slavery so when people say our
constitution has slavery built into its
dna they're not lying like that is
actually true the constitution would
never have been agreed to
if it hadn't included the three-fifths
compromise
you know and if it hadn't guaranteed the
slave trade would continue for at least
another 20 years
and if it hadn't had the fugitive slave
clause which committed
free states to returning slaves to their
masters that is to say it implicated the
free states in the practice of slavery
so you know those things are pretty
awful
and
slavery is indistinguishable in that
context from the principle of white
supremacy so when people say that
slavery and racism were baked into the
original constitution that's just a fact
and that was preserved through these
compromises but what lincoln did is he
broke the constitution in such a way as
to end that and he did it eventually by
emancipation which he himself believed
was unconstitutional when he started the
presidency
so this is also something that amazed me
he didn't just promise it
when
one of his generals
immediately once the war began started
freeing the slaves of confederates who
were um in his who came into his con
came into contact with him in his in his
district
lincoln ordered him to reverse it and
when he wouldn't reverse it
lincoln
retracted the order himself and fired
the general
so lincoln was couldn't be clear and he
wrote in a letter to his friend at the
same time listen to take people's slaves
is just dictatorship
i'm not gonna do that
fast forward 18 months
he's realized they're not going to win
the war easily he's realized compromise
is not going to work
he's realized that he has no basis for
convincing people to fight a war to save
the union if the union isn't moral
and he decides to
flip the the narrative
and to declare that slaves in the
confederacy are hereby free
even though
yeah by all means so this is as a
non-historian uh this this may just show
how ignorant i am but
was it in the service of
morality or was it to [ __ ]
or cause dis [ __ ] the south or cause
so much disorder so much quilombo
that the north could capitalize on it
effectively
it's a great great question and the
reason it's such a good question
is that the answer is actually not
totally clear because lincoln himself
obscured the answer
so lincoln
never
said
at any point
up to the emancipation proclamation and
he barely ever said afterwards
that he was doing it because slavery was
immoral
he kind of wanted everyone who hated
slavery to think that
but he didn't want to say it
instead the rationale that he gave
throughout was this is a war effort to
help us win the war
it will create greater disorder as
you're saying it will convince slaves to
flee their masters
it will
send a message to the south that there
is no compromise
he said all those things he said it was
necessary to win the war
he did not like to say that it was for
moral reasons
and he was criticized for that you know
at the time
by those who thought he should have been
more overt in saying that slavery was
fundamentally immoral
and historians are divided about whether
he secretly thought that it was actually
an important moral thing to do
or whether his real motivation was the
one that he stated namely this is a war
measure to win the war
and in researching it i actually came to
the conclusion
that
he didn't want to admit to himself that
he was doing it because slavery was
immoral
because he believed
that as president he was authorized to
win the war but he wasn't authorized to
impose his moral will on the rest of the
country
so he insisted even to himself that he
was doing it because it was necessary to
win the war
but i think unconsciously by then he had
realized that the old slavery compromise
could never work
and needed to be replaced with something
totally new and that that new thing
would be moral and this is sort of my
punchline of the book which is that
today
we all think that our constitution is a
moral blueprint
we think it's a kind of higher law we
might not always follow it and we we may
screw it up but we aspire to following
it
right we had segregation and now we say
that was unconstitutional it was unjust
it was wrong we didn't live up to our
highest aspirations
nobody thought that before the civil war
nobody thought the constitution was
moral
the
people who supported the constitution
knew it was a compromise with slavery
and a lot of them knew slavery was
immoral
and so the constitution was not
a moral document
there might be morals they were apart
from the constitution and a higher than
the constitution
so this was a core transformative moment
in our thinking about what it is to
govern ourselves
because we shifted from we have to do
some practical things to govern
ourselves to thinking no we should also
live morally
and to me that's like fundamentally
important for the question of how we
want to live together in the future
because we're not always going to agree
on what the right way to live is we're
not always going to agree on what's
moral but if we all agree that we should
be trying to live our lives to make the
world somewhat better than it is right
now
we actually have something that we can
look forward to coming together on that
is a mechanism for compromise and it's a
mechanism for overcoming polarization by
saying okay we don't agree on what to do
right now but do we agree on where we
want to be
do we agree on that we want to make the
country a better fairer a more just
place
and to me that is the mechanism we can
use
to compromise as a country and i think
it's also very practically usable by
anybody who's trying to work out the
future by looking at the past you ask
yourself how can i make it better
and the answer is usually by aspiring to
do that and then trying to reach
agreement on some concrete steps that we
could take
to try to make it better
this makes me think of
a story i was told
some time ago probably 10 years ago
and i can't remember the professor's
name but there it was it was a story
told me by a stanford professor who at
stanford was allowed to create and
experiment with new classes
of pretty much any type
so you could just say i'm going to teach
a class on something i just made up
during my nap or after my nap and we're
going to give it a shot and the class
was
intended to be focused on some aspect of
world peace all right
and students show up
so far so good
lots of students show up for this class
register for this class
and then it turns out uh oh we have a
problem
nobody can agree on what world peace
means and so you have you have people
from
the middle east on polar opposite ends
of the spectrum you have people from all
over
and what this particular professor ended
up doing was asking okay instead of
defining
world peace can we can we agree upon
and define some of the precursors
or constituent pieces of what world
peace might look like and they were able
to do that so they came up with
certain bits and pieces of this puzzle
which they agreed upon and that's what
they ended up spending the semester
focused on
and
i bring that up in part because
i'd love for you to
expand on this word compromise because i
think when a lot of people hear that
word
and sometimes i'm one of those people
particularly someone who uh let's just
say lincoln looks up to this other
figure idolizes him because he's the
master of compromise now there there's
there are people who will hear that and
say well that sounds like
no firm position
right you're you're the master of
waffling yep and it has a negative
connotation how do you think of this
this word compromise
i love that question and i love the
story too i never heard that before
that's totally fascinating
so here's how i think about it i think
you can divide compromise into two kinds
of compromise
one of which is waffling
and one of which is
let's call it better than waffling
um let's call it um
real aspiration
so the kind of compromise that is
waffling and sometimes you need this
kind of compromise in life
is where there's a zero sum thing
that you and somebody else are arguing
about but you know that you need to
cooperate
in order to keep your part of that
zero-sum
thing right two partners
in a business each owns 50 of the shares
you can't have 150 of the shares just by
definition you know that's just like not
the way it works
and they have to get along with each
other and they don't always agree on the
right course of conduct for the business
so in that situation
you actually need some degree of
call it
flexibility
in agreeing on what you're going to do
which means that sometimes you're going
to do something you think is wrong
right the other your partner is saying
we should do this and you're like look
dude i know you're wrong i've been we've
been doing this for a long time i'm i
know when i'm right i'm right the same
you're wrong your friend is like nope
it's the other way around i know that
i'm right this is one of the cases where
you're wrong if you can't waffle that is
if you can't be flexible and say okay
we're going to do it your way this time
even though i know it's wrong
you're just going to fail you're going
to break up
so
that's the kind of compromise that
was happening before the civil war that
was the waffling compromise
and you can see that it was lousy
because it involved a lousy thing namely
slavery
but without it they wouldn't have been
able to build the union
the united states would not have gone
from a tiny little i-95 nation you know
on the east coast
you know eastern seaboard country to a
continental power
without this kind of
agreement or compromise now there were a
few people who were like we don't need
to be that let's just stay on
let's just you know let's just stay on
the uh sell a car door and that's that's
plenty for us but most people were like
no we want to actually expand this thing
and to do that you had to have that kind
of compromise
but here's the other kind of compromise
and this is the one i want to call real
aspiration
that's when we actually do look at each
other and say
we agree on a broader objective
that involves making the world actively
better
and we both want to achieve that
objective let's say in the case of the
constitution it's equality right let's
say in the case of some you know of a
business it's transforming some sphere
of dom or domain of interests you know
let's say it's in psychedelic research
it's expanding the capacities of human
consciousness and enabling people to be
healed
better than they are now through that
objective these are big grand objectives
they're stated at a very high degree of
generality because they have to be
but they're really important
and they're hugely important and then
what we say listen i'm going to go along
with what you want to do in this
situation because i see us as involved
in a collective experiment to try to get
us to this end and we both want that
same end and i'm going to try to do it
your way now and you're going to try to
do it my way the next time and we are
going to do a little bit of compromise
but it's not because i i won't be saying
i know you're wrong i'll be saying i
think this other route might be faster
where it's like we're both hiking up the
mountain and the path forks we know both
forks go up the mountain
and we're trying to figure out like
which one will get us there faster or
better and so i go with you i still
think my way was better
but i know we're still going up the
mountain at that same objective and that
seems to me to be the good kind of
compromise
that isn't just
waffling
are there any
alive or dead any figures who stand out
to you is particularly good at crafting
productive
compromise
who we haven't talked about already
i mean we mentioned nelson mandela in
passing he's an example of somebody who
was able to convince all south africans
that they actually had a common
objective of living together even though
just a short time before he had been
imprisoned and you know a good part of
the country thought their objective was
to keep him and people like him
subordinated so he's you know he's a
cliched example but there's a reason
that he's a cliched example because he
really did have that kind of a
transformative capacity um to to work
together and compromise
i think you know
in the united states
martin luther king jr is another great
example of someone who was capable of
compromise to achieve those sorts of
things and he has got a nice parallel in
malcolm x who was not so inclined to
compromise with injustice and they each
show you the value of those two
different kinds of approaches i think
they were really interesting compare and
contrast for that reason they're each
seeking equality they're each seeking
justice one is saying we should do this
by a collective undertaking
of a higher objective and the other is
saying no we should do this by the
people who are doing bad things should
stop doing those bad things and if not i
will do everything i can all means
necessary are appropriate to getting us
there and i have a great respect for
each
approach
those stand out
strongly in my mind as
you know forms of the productive
aspirational
type of compromise
who is oliver wendell holmes jr
and uh why are you interested in him so
oliver wendell holmes jr was
most famous as a supreme court justice
who served for a long time
between the
very very early years of the 20th
century and into the very early 1930s
before that he was the son of a
nationally famous writer
who volunteered the day the civil war
began when he was in college
to go to war
got shot
in his very first battle
luckily for him got shot in the front
and not in the butt
and went back to massachusetts where he
was already a bit of a celebrity because
his father was famous and he was very
tall and good-looking
and he was
fetid in every um you know salon in
massachusetts as this hero of the civil
war which he really liked he really
liked being a hero
he then went back out to battle got shot
a second time and was so he was so
scared of getting shot that he had um
he had actually filled his flask with
poison
but his sergeant knew he had done this
and emptied it and refilled it with gin
and so when he was shot the second time
he drank the flask thinking that he was
gonna like commit suicide because anyone
have his legs sawn off
but he just got super he just got super
drunk
and the sergeant saved his life
he then he then went to law school
set himself up as a young lawyer
and actually turn to history to try to
understand the future and
when talking about using history
understand the past i realized just in
this moment i never thought of it before
that holmes is actually an amazing
example of this and he wrote a little
book called the common law which was a
total re-reading of the history
of
the law basically the law of accidents
and contracts
and it was a radical re-reading of the
history and his central argument was
that as he put it the life of the law
has not been logic
it has been experience
so his idea was that law presents itself
as all logical all the time and it's
[ __ ]
law is actually
a set of institutions by which we
constantly update and upgrade and up
level our society as we're doing it
on the basis of things we've screwed up
and in the hopes of doing it better in
the future
and in this he was an archetypal
pragmatist
and he actually hung out with a group of
people they called themselves the
metaphysical club who were all
pragmatists and they were famous
pragmatists william james
hugely famous
psychologist also very rightly famous as
one of the first people to seriously
expand his consciousness using drugs and
writing write it down um he was
constantly self-experimenting he took
every drug that was known to him and he
was a pragmatist and central figure in
pragmatism because he thought that life
was constantly about experimenting and
holmes agreed with him
cs purse another contemporary of theirs
who formalized pragmatism into a logical
system
uh henry adams holmes hung out with
these guys he was the best looking
he definitely slept with the girlfriends
of several of the others
there there are some historians who
speculate that he slept with some of the
other members of the club although
that's purely at the level of
speculation so holmes was very
intellectually attracted to this idea of
societal pragmatism
seen as experiment to him pragmatism was
seeing that as he put it later in his
life it is an experiment as all life is
an experiment that's his you know his
real tagline
now this dude who was an elite elite
elite yankee they called him the yankee
from olympus
it was what we would call today a high
wasp
he got old he got onto the supreme court
and he found himself basically forgotten
time had passed him by he still dressed
like it was the civil war he wore a huge
cavalry mustache a military mustache
from the civil war
and he had an amazing second life
because when he was in his 80s he was
discovered by a group of young
progressive lawyers chief among them
felix frankfurter who went on to become
a professor at harvard law school and
then a supreme court justice himself
and they were looking for
a poster child
for
their progressivism
and they could have picked louis
brandeis who was a rough contemporary of
holmes also a genius
also a supreme court justice but
brandeis was jewish and was actually
himself a progressive and they wanted a
better poster child
and they they hit on homes
and
they were able to do it by getting
holmes
to basically say
something that he believed which was
that the government shouldn't stop you
from experimenting
the supreme court shouldn't block
experiments so he looked at
progressivism and he was like you want
to do a lot of experiments i'm not sure
any of it's going to work
in fact i'm cynical and i don't really
believe it'll work but you should be
able to do it
whereas the conservative members of
supreme court the time were like no
if you're going to experiment with
progressive laws that limit hours
that you know that give you a minimum
wage we're going to strike those down
and holmes because he believed in
experimentation took the view like no
we're not going to strike those down so
he wasn't really a progressive but they
barred him for that purpose and they
made him a mega celebrity and he loved
it
and as a consequence he went down in
history as one of the greatest justices
of all time mostly because he was always
saying look let the experiment run let
the experiment run
and that was his core judicial
philosophy it also last thought on this
it also made him a pioneer of free
speech
because you can't
experiment if you can't share your ideas
so the core idea is we need to have free
speech so that we can keep experimenting
i'm so glad that i asked
about
the
the yankee from olympus
yeah that's incredible
how did you first get a b in your bonnet
about all for wendell holmes jr
you know when i went to law school i
went to yale law school no one ever
talked about holmes it was like
i mean i wouldn't say he didn't exist
but no one was interested in him
then i came to teach at harvard law
school hold on pause one second how
could you not be interested in this
person
why is that that seems so odd to me i
mean i
i'll be honest he wasn't presented
you know in new haven connecticut he
just wasn't presented as someone
we really needed to care about
that much he was kind of old-fashioned
and i should add holmes had plenty of
non-admirable characteristics
i mean
he thought he was so cool he thought he
was so awesome
and
he of course had all the prejudices of
his day
so he you know he supported eugenics
and in one supreme court decision
notorious decision called buck against
bell
where the state of virginia was forcibly
sterilizing people whom it determined to
be quote unquote you know mentally
inferior
we would say developmentally challenged
and though it's not even clear they were
holmes upheld that practice
and he used the following line three
generations of imbeciles are enough
i mean horrible stuff so there was
plenty not to like somehow that was what
was always emphasized
and then i came to harvard his portrait
is everywhere
and it's like he like looms over the
place
in a meaningful way and i said all right
i'm gonna revisit and i read a book that
actually i love called the metaphysical
club by a person called louis minand
who's an amazing amazing writer he's a
professor at harvard in the english
department book won the pulitzer prize
it's an amazing amazing book the
metaphysical club and it's a group
biography of those people i was just
describing and one of the chapters is
about holmes
and it's a totally gripping chapter and
then i was like okay i'm gonna give this
guy some deeper thought and as i teach
constitutional law and the first
amendment which are two of the classes
that i teach
he just emerges as this really
fascinating
central figure and that got me much more
deeply fascinated by him now i have not
yet he's been a minor character in a
book that i wrote i have not sat down to
write a book just about him and partly
it's because i'm scared to
felix frankford when he was a professor
in the supreme court justice he assigned
his favorite student to write the
biography of holmes that's a hell of an
assignment the guy couldn't do it he
couldn't do it
he had a nervous breakdown
and then he died young
good lord what happened he was a
brilliant brilliant scholar why did it
break him it's not like for matt's last
theorem i mean it's writing a biography
but was it just because of
with the good you get the bad and equal
intensity i mean i don't really know i
think the grandeur was so significant
the life was so powerful and long
that
it just seemed i think it just seemed
overwhelming
and it doesn't mean he's just a human
being
he lived a life he did a lot of stuff
but he spent a lot of time as a judge
and you know frankly judges lives are
lived what's interesting about a judge's
life is primarily what they write you
know it's not primarily what they do
every day i mean holmes got up he read
all day then he did some writing
you know i mean those were his main life
activities so it's not like the book
would be so action-packed that you
you know that you couldn't write it and
there have been lots of other
biographies of homes over the years
i think it was probably just that
frankfurter was so worshipful of holmes
and he was telling him the student to
write something worshipful and you can't
write a good biography if it's
worshipful it's going to be horribly
boring
so i haven't done it and uh but i will
write something about holmes at some
point i'm sure
well another option
walter isaacson has been on the podcast
a few times we could go have some drinks
with walter and try to get a b in his
bonnet that's a good idea that's a
really good idea
that's a much better idea
he's not that far from austin uh these
days and i you know i have
a question this this may just be a dead
end but i've always wanted to ask and
have never done the homework myself
did the iroquois confederacy have any
impact
on our constitution because i've heard
that as a
passing comment before and i never knew
if there was any truth to it
there is something to it for sure
so
the way i think of it is is the
following and i should say i'm not i'm
not an expert on the iroquois
confederacy at all but i'm really
interested in it so
the iroquois confederacy was a group of
tribes native american american indian
tribes who realized a lot earlier than a
lot of other
tribes did
that if they were going to a defeat
other tribes
and b
stand up against
the rising tide of european settlement
they could not do it alone
they had to group themselves together
into a broader
alliance
with some degree of collective
governance
now they didn't have a full state
and
so it wasn't as though they had like a
central governor who could govern or a
central legislature but they did have
a series of decision-making methods
through the consultation groups of the
individual tribes and individual bands
up to this level of the confederacy
and the founders
knew about the iroquois confederacy
because it was right there
interacting with them
and they dealt with it
and so when
james madison was trying to work out the
ideas that became federalism
which is after all a similar idea the
idea that you should have a
confederation you should have
shared decision making on some big level
things while maintaining your individual
sovereignty over some smaller level
things
he was interested in every confederacy
he could think of
and in his notes on confederacies that
he created for himself he went all the
way back to the ancient world
and looked at some greek and roman
predecessors he was particularly
interested in one truly obscure thing
called the amphitheonic league
which he cared about a lot i just love
saying m fictionic um
and uh he was also interested in modern
confederacies so he looked in
confederation so he was really
interested in holland for example which
had a person who sort of functioned as a
semi-king he's called the start holder
and
but also was organized into these
individual sub-units
and he didn't write about the iroquois
confederacy in those notes
because there weren't very many books
written about it
and he was writing notes on the books he
was reading his notes were literally
like his reading notes
but he was certainly aware of the
iroquois confederacy as were the other
framers and so in that milieu when they
were coming up with federalism
they had a practical example of a
version of it uh directly facing them so
in that sense i think it is fair to say
that it was you know part of the
the thought world that they were engaged
with
thank you
what are you most excited about
right now
looking forward over the next
six to 12 months
you could pick any time frame really
what are you what are you excited about
i'm really excited about some
innovations
in
governance
in big tech
that i've had a chance to be a little
bit involved in
that are experiments we were just
talking about experiments and how if you
want to try to make the world any better
than it currently is you have to try
stuff out and see if it's going to work
or not work and i'm really interested
and excited because i want to see if
these experiments are going to work and
if they do how they work and if they
don't work i want to see how they they
don't work so the one that um is
directly in front of my my eyes right
now is the facebook oversight board
which sometimes people call the supreme
court of facebook
which uh launched
not quite a year ago and
which i was directly involved in in
launching and coming up with
and
which is based on the idea that there's
a series of decisions
that are too important to be made by the
leadership of a platform that has
you know well over two billion users you
know pushing on three billion users
and so the core idea behind this
oversight board
was that start with an identifiable set
of decisions about what content facebook
allows on its site and what content it
takes down and what people it allows on
its site and what people it d platforms
so start with that narrowly defined
problem it's not the only problem
facebook faces by any stretch of the
imagination but it's an important
problem
and
take ultimate decision power about that
away from the company and put it in an
independent group of people who are paid
by an independent trust
the money came from facebook but it goes
into when it went into an independent
trust a couple hundred million went to
this independent trust to administer and
run this oversight board
and give them genuine oversight by
facebook promising that it will do what
it tells them to do
and
running the experiment to see if this
group can do a better job than facebook
in making the decisions
see if it can hold facebook to account
and try to push facebook to make its own
decisions in a more regularized
rule-based way
and see if it's possible to show the
world in fact if it is working
that there's a benefit
for private companies to do what
governments have long done namely have
some real separation of powers
right namely say that there's some
things that you know we just don't want
the president congress to decide we
don't want the president congress to
decide what speech is allowed in what
speech isn't allowed because we know
they would follow their interests so we
have an independent supreme court that
has it's not that it doesn't have
interest but has a different set of
interests
and it's more independent
and historically we haven't really seen
companies doing this companies are seen
as serving the interests of their
shareholders and that interest has
traditionally been seen as making a
profit for their shareholders
while not violating the law
increasingly we now see in our world
that's not good enough right we want
companies to do more than just make
money and not break the law we want them
to actually contribute to the public
good so this is a humongous experiment
and it's still unclear if it will work
and how well it will work but i'm really
excited to see how it plays out
how will you know if the experiment has
worked what would be indications
evidence to point to it working
if the oversight board rubber stamps
everything that facebook does it's not
working
it needs to make independent decisions
that reverse facebook
if it makes decisions then facebook
doesn't implement them it's not working
facebook has to actually implement
decisions that facebook doesn't like
if the public looks at this entity two
years from now and says
this is bs
you know these people aren't really
independent
their decision making isn't really
making the world better then it's not
working
but on the other hand if people say oh
that actually it was an independent
decision and it's not not what facebook
necessarily wanted then that would be a
marker of success
so we had an intro market of success
when the facebook oversight board
weighed in on the decision to
de-platform donald trump
it ultimately said that
facebook had done it wrong but that if
they did it again and did it right
they would be permitted to keep him off
the platform for some period of time
and that got reported on on the front
page of every newspaper and for the most
part the press treated it as an
independent decision which i think in
practice it actually was
and that was i would say a first step to
success i wouldn't call it
success at the end state by any stretch
of the imagination but a first step
towards success that was meaningful
because the world treated it as
independent and it was independent and
it wasn't just a rubber stamp
but it was also not and of course a lot
of people have been very angry if they
had made facebook put donald trump back
on right so inevitably people are going
to be angry no matter what decision they
made and i think the board kind of split
the difference by saying we're going to
tell you you did a wrong facebook but
we're also going to tell you that if you
do it right you're allowed to keep them
off the platform so that was a kind of a
compromise
debate whether it was the kind of
compromise we were talking about of the
best kind or the not best kind so those
are the kinds of landmarks that i think
will be testable and one last thing
if other
tech companies
think about their own kinds of novel
governance solutions which would not
necessarily look like the oversight
board
but if they adopted other kinds of
creative outside the box solutions that
share power
to show the public that they are trying
to do better than they're doing
then that would be yet another marker
of the success of this experiment
because you know there's no there's no
success like you know invitation is the
serious form of flattery because
imitation shows you that other people
think something is working
let's go back to
the invasion of iraq you mentioned that
not to compare the two things but i will
you mentioned that there
there were best practices
clearly visible uh or i should say worst
practices clearly visible right if you
if you want to invade a country here are
the five things you shouldn't do
as you're looking at the supreme court
of x that could be the supreme court of
facebook could be the supreme court of
google now some people could argue the
supreme court of any of these companies
should actually stand outside of these
companies completely
but
okay so what would be
foreseeable common mistakes
uh that you think people should pay
attention to avoiding
when trying to create these types of of
boards for instance just what comes to
mind is and i think about this in the
realm of science as well
potential conflicts of interest right so
if the board of facebook
or the supreme court of facebook is
comprised of members who are
incentivized with facebook stock how do
we think about that
right that would be a disaster that's a
great example of what not to do
so you do need to have genuine
independence
and that means compensation has to be
from some external entity
it means
their reappointment to the board when
their term is up
which i think under the facebook rules
can happen once
can't be anything to do with the company
so it can't be that the company has any
say in that
so that's another one an important one
uh yet another thing mistake to avoid
is
giving the new entity the court or the
board or whatever it is
giving it so much power up front
that it could make decisions that would
break the company
right i mean because if you want
companies to
be able to
build on this and take the decision
seriously they have to be making
decisions that are within the realm of
what they could do
without
portraying the duty that they owe to
their shareholders so you need to
it's kind of it's kind of it sounds
contradictory but you have to be modest
enough in defining the overall goals
that the board won't find itself
telling the company to do something the
company just can't do you know
fundamentally can't do and i've learned
the hard way that in tech sometimes
saying you have modest goals doesn't
convince everybody sometimes people want
to hear that your solution will solve
every problem and just like i said
earlier the constitutions can't solve
every problem new governance solutions
can't solve every problem but they can
address some of the problems
another mistake would be
if these entities
were
making global decisions
but were only made up of americans
if you're making global decisions you
need representation from all over the
globe you need people from all over if
you're making decisions for the u.s you
could be u.s focused if you're making
decisions for britain you could be
britain focused or you know and so forth
but if it's going to be truly a global
decision-making body it needs to be
global in its orientation
and the last thing is
you need to actually have some
values stated in advance that you're
going to try to pursue
and you need to be transparent about how
your decisions reach those i think the
big one of the biggest mistakes you
could make would be to make decisions
behind closed doors and not explain why
you're making them i think
in this day and age
we're all cynical we all know how the
world works and so we
need to be able to hear you say this is
why i'm making the decision here's why i
might be wrong
but here's why i made the decision that
i made i think transparency drives
transparency and giving reasons
drives legitimacy non-transparency or
failure to give reasons
detracts from legitimacy
and legitimacy is sort of the
the currency right of so many different
domains whether it's
a
blockchain whether it's
constitution whether it's the supreme
court of facebook and you talked about
this this potentially global
representation for global business it's
it's
makes me think of the potential of say
the united nations of facebook and then
you have these parallel structures that
on some level mimic these outside
organizations within these larger
companies
and on the
point of transparency are the decisions
of
just for simplicity again the supreme
court of facebook made public
regardless of
if or how the company ends up heeding
that advice
yes the oversight board issues those
decisions on its website it makes them
public
and
then it tells facebook to implement them
and if facebook doesn't implement them
right i expect that the oversight board
will do what it has the power to do
which is to call out facebook publicly
on that
you know they they can say to facebook
privately first like hey do it we said
do it but then if facebook doesn't do it
they can say publicly you didn't do it
and ultimately that's where the power of
the
external entity lies right i mean
its power is that the company has
promised to do what they've told them to
do and if they don't then they're lying
and the board will be able to draw
attention to that so
the baseline idea is that it's in the
interests of companies to be seen as
doing what they've promised and you know
when you're a company like facebook that
has tremendous challenges
in terms of how people believe it
operates there's only one way out of
that and that way is to consistently
demonstrate over an extended period of
time that you are following the rules
that you are disclosing that you are
transparent
and you know over time it will take time
no question
you can rebuild a reputation for
transparency honesty openness and
legitimacy and no one is disputing that
that is a long road but the only way to
make a long journey is to put one foot
in front of the other and start making
the damn journey
and so i see the oversight board as an
experiment that's designed to try
to push the company in that direction
and enable the company to go in that
direction it can't force it
you know it it
opens the possibility of that and again
that's why i call it an experiment
are there any other experiments it could
be outside of
this particular example
any other experiments that you're
looking forward to whether
you are a part of them or they are
outside of yourself
well an experiment that i wouldn't say
exactly that i'm looking forward to it
but i'm watching it with constant
fascination as i think a lot of us are
is how are we as a world gonna try to
come out of the covent pandemic i mean
that's an experiment in real time and
real human lives are at stake and a huge
amount turns on how well we do it not
just in the us
or in the developed you know richer
countries
but everywhere
because
you know i mean
a virus does not know borders
and
a virus that spreads in one area of the
world unchecked is going to evolve
because it's just a principle basic
principle of evolutionary biology that
if you have
a larger and larger quantum of the virus
circulating the probability of it
mutating in such a way as to become more
dangerous increases so it's in
everybody's interest
for there to be as little covet out
there as there can possibly be
and that means we need world
coordination of a kind that we have not
yet fully seen
we need sharing of resources in a way
that we've seen the beginnings of but we
have not yet fully seen
and we all need that we need that
desperately so this is a kind of grand
global experiment in can we work
together
and in a sense the climate change
challenge is similar
and there we do see results but we don't
necessarily see the results quite as
quickly as we're seeing it in the
context of covet covert we're seeing it
you know very very much
in in real time and
you know covet is also i mean climate is
ultimately existential for us as the
species covets probably not existential
for us as a species but it is a pretty
damn big problem and real human beings
are you know losing their lives and
it has tremendous negative consequences
and drag on everything we do as as not
only as a country but as a society and
as a globe
and so you know i think we're all
watching that with like total
fascination and attention and trying to
figure out in real time as it goes
noah
you're a hell of a guy i am so
constantly
every time we chat impressed with the
breadth and depth of your intellectual
curiosity and the way that you're able
to tie disparate times places
people
together with pattern recognition it's
really astonishing and really impressive
and i know it's
i know that you have good hardware but
it's also a trained skill so i want to
just
give you a bow for that because it's
very very impressive and it's a valuable
skill that contributes to the collective
is there anything
else you would like to say
ask of my audience call attention to
anything at all
before we wrap up this conversation well
i will we'll hopefully do a round two at
some point because i mean we didn't
talk about free speech really
we did not talk about your new class and
thoughts on ethics and power
i didn't get to dive into a.i there are
a million other things we could get into
but
for this conversation i didn't get to
ask you why the metaphysical club has
met a physical in the title
which is going to bother me but i'll
figure it out
but but for this conversation is there
anything you would like to add as
closing comments
requests of the audience anything at all
well first of all back at you tim you
know in your work and in your podcast
you're literally interested in
everything i mean it's such a
fascinating podcast to listen to because
you never know from week to week what
extraordinary topic it will explore and
you know always there'll be something
actionable that comes out of it um but
you also know that it it'll be
associative and in talking to you every
time i've talked to you and certainly in
this conversation too
you're doing it in real time you know
you're coming up with connections and
ideas and putting it together so i'm
super grateful for that and i benefit
from it like all your listeners do and i
loved talking to you in this
conversation about that
i'll just say for
for listeners
i spent a good amount of my time trying
to produce ideas and and put them out
there and so i'd love to reach you guys
and i'd love to have you tell me what
you're interested in because i see it as
a dialogue
a huge number of the ideas that i have
for things to write about and think
about
come from directly from
things that people write to me and and
tell me
so um you know you can certainly read my
columns on on bloomberg or listen to the
deep background podcast
or you know read my books if you happen
to come across them
i also have a website
noaa feldman.com
where you can sign up if you want to
hear from me on an intermittent basis i
promise not to spam you or irritate you
but primarily it gives you the
opportunity to communicate with me and
that is of tremendous tremendous value
in education for me so i want to just
say that to listeners and i love to love
to talk to all of you and engage with
you
and i just want to express deep
gratitude tim to you for
all the work that you do and for giving
me a chance to chat with you
what a gift to have this time with you
noah thank you so much noah feldman
ladies and gentlemen on twitter at noah
r feldman as he mentioned noah
heifenfeldman.com we will link
to
everything in the show notes as usual at
tim dot blog podcast the new book
check it out is the broken constitution
subtitled lincoln slavery and the
refounding of america
what
fun to be able to explore so many topics
i can't wait for the next time we get to
hang in person
and
to everybody listening
until next time
be safe experiment well
look for the good kinds of compromise
when the opportunities arise
and thanks for tuning in
you